[Music]
welcome to the huberman lab guest Series
where I and an expert guest discuss
science and science-based tools for
everyday life
I'm Andrew huberman and I'm a professor
of neurobiology and Ophthalmology at
Stanford School of Medicine
today's episode marks the second episode
in our four episode series with Dr Paul
Conte about mental health the first
episode in the series dealt with how to
understand and assess your level of
mental health today's episode is about
how to improve your mental health I do
want to emphasize that you do not need
to have heard or seen the first episode
in order to understand or glean
important information from today's
episode about how to improve your mental
health but I do encourage you to go and
listen to the first episode at some
point if you have not already
today's episode deals with several
topics important to all of us as well as
protocols to improve one's mental health
for instance you will learn how to guide
yourself through a process of
self-inquiry in which you address
certain key questions about your drives
your level of aggressive Drive pleasure
drive and the so-called generative Drive
these are essential things to understand
about oneself if you want to guide
yourself toward your aspirations and if
you want to understand how your
subconscious processing is influencing
your thoughts and your behaviors and
your feelings in ways that sometimes
serve your aspirations and in other ways
that can hinder your aspirations Dr
Conti shares with us a way of assessing
our internal narratives as well as a way
of creating a constructive
self-awareness and an understanding of
where those narratives and that
self-awareness stem from in our
childhood so that we can navigate
forward with the greatest sense of
agency we also talk about how to move
past common hindrances to improving
one's mental health such as overcoming
intrusive thoughts and perhaps most
importantly today's episode provides
information and protocols that anyone
can use to cultivate their generative
Drive which is a Hallmark of mental
health just a reminder that Dr Paul
Conte has generously provided a few
diagrams that we include as PDFs in the
show note captions they are completely
zero cost to access and they can help
you understand some of the material that
was discussed in the first episode of
the series as well as the current
episode about how to improve your mental
health and while those simple PDF
diagrams are certainly not necessary in
order to understand the material in
today's discussion or in the other
discussions of this series many people
find them useful so I encourage you to
check out those links in the show note
captions before we begin I'd like to
emphasize that this podcast is separate
from my teaching and research roles at
Stanford it is however part of my desire
and effort to bring zero cost to
Consumer information about science and
science related tools to the general
public in keeping with that theme I'd
like to thank the sponsors of today's
podcast our first sponsor is betterhelp
betterhelp offers Professional Therapy
with a licensed therapist carried out
online I personally have been doing
weekly therapy for more than 30 years
and while that Weekly therapy was
initiated not by my own request it was
in fact a requirement for me to remain
in high school over time I really came
to appreciate just how valuable doing
quality therapy is in fact I look at
doing quality therapy much in the same
way that I look at going to the gym or
doing cardiovascular training such as
running as ways to enhance my physical
health I see therapy as a vital way to
enhance one's mental health the beauty
of better help is that they make it very
easy to find an excellent therapist an
excellent therapist can be defined as
somebody who is going to be very
supportive of you in an objective way
with whom you have excellent rapport
with and who can help you arrive at Key
insights that you wouldn't have
otherwise been able to find and because
better help therapy is conducted
entirely online it's extremely
convenient and easy to incorporate into
the rest of your life so if you're
interested in better help go to
betterhelp.com huberman to get 10 off
your first month that's better help
spelled help.com huberman today's
episode is also brought To Us by waking
up waking up is a meditation app that
offers dozens of guided meditation
sessions mindfulness trainings yoga
needs recessions and more
by now there's an abundance of data
showing that even short daily
meditations can greatly improve our mood
reduce anxiety improve our ability to
focus and can improve our memory and
while there are many different forms of
meditation most people find it difficult
to find and stick to a meditation
practice in a way that is most
beneficial for them the waking up app
makes it extremely easy to learn how to
meditate and to carry out your daily
meditation practice in a way that's
going to be most effective and efficient
for you it includes a variety of
different types of meditations of
different duration as well as things
like Yoga Nidra which place the brain
and body into a sort of pseudo sleep
that allows you to emerge feeling
incredibly mentally refreshed in fact
the science around Yoga Nidra is really
impressive showing that after a Yoga
Nidra session levels of dopamine in
certain areas of the brain are enhanced
by up to 60 percent which places the
brain and body into a state of enhanced
Readiness for mental work and for
physical work another thing I really
like about the waking up app is that it
provides a 30 day day introduction
course so for those of you that have not
meditated before or getting back to a
meditation practice that's fantastic or
if you're somebody who's already a
skilled and regular meditator waking up
has more advanced meditations and yoga
need your sessions for you as well if
you'd like to try the waking up app you
can go to wakingup.com huberman and
access a free 30-day trial again that's
wakingup.com huberman and now for my
discussion about mental health with Dr
Paul Conte Dr Conti welcome back thank
you in the first episode of this series
you laid out for us in a very structured
way you know what true mental health
looks like essentially what we should
all be aspiring to and he touched on
these themes of agency and gratitude as
uh verb States really ways of being in
the world yes that allow everybody to
have some sense of well-being to have
some sense of themselves in a way that
is kind to themselves and to others and
really to feel good and do good in their
life and without question this is what
people want right you also spelled out
for us these two pillars the structure
of self and the function of self that
consists of a number of different things
that from which geyser up or kind of you
know give rise to these feelings of
empowerment humility agency and
gratitude and reminded us several times
that when we are challenged when we're
not doing as well as we would like that
we need to look back to the structure of
self and the function of self and ask
specific questions in order to arrive or
re-arrive at the sense of agency and
gratitude yes
I think it would be wonderful for us if
you could just sort of recap the overall
model because it has the components that
I just mentioned but there's some
subtlety and some really key aspects of
these pillars structure of self and
function of self and I think if people
keep in mind for today's episode which
is about challenges that people commonly
face and even if you will phenotypes
that we see commonly out there for
people that haven't heard of phenotypes
phenotypes are the typical appearance of
something so there is the phenotype of
the anxious person the phenotype of the
person who just can't seem to get out of
a rut there's the phenotype of the
traumatized person and these things play
out differently in in different
individuals men and women boys and girls
but we're going to visit many of the
most common phenotypes out there and
think about how to do better be better
feel better through the lens of the
model that was spelled out in episode
one and of course if people have not
seen or heard episode 1
today's discussion will still be
entirely accessible to them so in
keeping with that if you could just give
us an overview of what this structure of
the healthy self looks like as a road
map for uh where we're all headed today
thank you thanks very much
um revisiting the the pillars is is I
think the best place to start because
there really are routes to understanding
and if we understand then we can
strategize we can make change right we
can make things better so the the first
pillar the structure of self starts with
the unconscious mind right this
incredibly complicated biological
supercomputer that's firing a mile a
minute right underneath the surface in
us and is throwing up to the surface all
sorts of thoughts and ideas and states
that then the conscious mind apprehends
and our awareness comes into play and
then we have defense mechanisms that
sort of Rise Up from the unconscious
mind and they they Circle and sort of
gird themselves around the conscious
mind which they can do in an unhealthy
way or in a healthy way or any anything
in between and then the the character
structure is sort of the nest around all
of that and it's from the character
structure that we that we are engaging
in the world in the way is that we're
engaging whether it's our active
engagement with the world around us and
the idea is that the self grows out of
that it grows out of that Nest sitting
on top of the unconscious mind to the
conscious mind Rising above the defense
mechanisms and the character structure
and and if we go back to that when we're
trying to understand ourselves you know
we're trying to understand states of
Health as well as states of unhappiness
or or states that aren't healthy right
by by going back and looking at the
structure we can learn a tremendous
amount and the other side the the other
pillar is the the function of self and
it really starts with the self-awareness
right the awareness of hey there is an
eye right I am in the world right this
is 24 hours in the day are going to pass
today and I'm going to be doing one
thing or another I'm I'm so I'm to some
very significant extent deciding how am
I going to engage in the world around me
during that time right so on top of that
are the defense mechanisms in actions so
defense mechanisms remember are
unconscious so there's a lot then going
on inside of us that's determining so
sort of the field set of options right
there may be a lot of automaticity that
narrows down the set of options of what
we may entertain what we may be aware of
what we may decide and that could happen
For Better or For Worse depending upon
the health of the defense mechanisms but
on top of that lies Salient so the idea
then we would next visit okay what are
we paying attention to right what's
coming from inside what's coming from
outside and we have to not pay attention
to many many many many things in order
to pay attention to whatever our
attention is alighted on at the moment
so it's a complex process and it's worth
looking at very closely if we want to
understand ourselves so after thinking
about the the defense mechanisms in
action right the unconscious aspects of
how we're engaging with the world then
next to consider is salience which is
sort of where does the Mind arrive at at
rest right where does the Mind Trend
towards is it something internal is it
something external what are all the
things we're not paying attention to in
order to pay attention to something and
is that thing healthy is it not healthy
is it serving us well so there's so much
to understand about salience and then
The Next Step Beyond that is
understanding Behavior right how are we
engaging with the world around us what
are our behavioral choices what are our
automatic behaviors and then sitting on
top of all of that or our strivings so
we we have a sense of wanting something
in the world around us like what is that
and how are we trying to get to it and
how does it make us feel so if we look
at the 10 elements right the five under
the structure of self and the five under
the function of self then what we're
really looking at is is sort of like
looking at 10 cabinets right and if
we're trying to understand ourselves
whether we're trying to just generally
understand ourselves or we're trying to
get at a problem right then looking at
all 10 of those cabinets makes sense
right some of them will be bare meaning
that they may seem to have very little
to do with the problem we're bringing
and we kind of maintain an open mind we
may be led back to that cabin and there
may be something there but what usually
happens is if we look in all 10 places
we find a couple where there's there's
some rich material to explore sort of
the x marks the spot and then we go and
we we dig there to sort of mix the
metaphors we we dig in the cabinet where
we're going to find something right and
then it leads forward a process of
understanding and if we're bringing
those things into line where we have a
healthy structure of self and a healthy
function of self and we're aware of all
of this and we're working on it we're
self-aware and we're paying attention to
everything built on top of that then
what we end up with is a sense of
humility because one cannot be anything
but respectful compassion and
understanding the complexity of of all
of this and understanding how does it
manifest itself in us and and just the
very fact that we can wake our ways in
the world right is so just is so
impressive and in a way I think it
brings to us a respect just a respect
for being here navigating the the world
and I think of that respect is born
humility the complexity of us the fact
that millions of things are going on
underneath the surface millions of of
neurotransmission and endocrinological
function all this is going on under the
surface I'm not even aware of it and
then it kicks up to the surface
generates a tremendous amount of respect
for the complexity and also the
diligence and perseverance it takes us
to navigate through the world and I
think built upon that understanding is a
sense of humility and a sense of
empowerment and the humility and
empowerment in action right so so
expressed right become agency and
gratitude and agency and gratitude as
you said at the beginning we're seeing
as verbs right that's like how we're
living life it's it's through the lens
so to speak of agency and gratitude that
we're actively living and again I would
put forth that when we look at measures
of human happiness right across
disciplines and across time this is
always what we see is is some way of
describing how agency and gratitude
together as verbs manifest and then
create happiness it's the state that
we're seeking to be in right because
from that state of active agency and
active gratitude we achieve what it is
that I think we're really searching for
and you know there are by infinite words
throughout human history to describe
what that is we might choose to use
words like peacefulness a sense of Peace
a sense of contentment uh being
delighted by things like just being
amazed and impressed by things in the
world around us like this is a state
that we're striving for and I think when
people talk about happiness and what
we're really trying to get to it's this
right but it's not that these things are
passive right these things are coming
from the active agency the act of
gratitude and they're then interacting
with a generative Drive within us we
have an aggressive drive we have a
pleasure drive like this has been
thought about now for long long time
within mental health and validated in a
lot of ways but what hasn't been
validated is that they're the only
things right we see human beings
striving we see human beings wanting
better for themselves and for the world
around them we see acts of kindness that
seem to be rooted to nothing other than
the act of kindness we have within us a
drive to know to understand to learn to
make better and that has been described
as many many things across human history
but I think the words we might choose
are a generative drive a drive to create
and to make better and it's the
generative drive as something active
within us right that is then aligning
with agency and gratitude right the
active ways in which we express
ourselves and then that all together
brings us the peace the contentment the
sense of delight sometimes that may
exist in us in a state of rest right but
very often it's in it's existing in us
in a state of activity right and that's
why people find you know the quote
unquote happiness like what people are
seeking not just in you know meditation
sometimes we can find it there but
people also find it in in action right
they find it in doing that thing that
they love to do or taking care of
someone and learning something so when
we look at all of this we we can then we
can then have a route of understanding
what is going on inside of us and how we
can make the changes that let us be in
this state which is really the state
that we're seeking I really appreciate
that you highlight that agency and
gratitude are verb States
from which peace contentment and Delight
emerge and also the way that you explain
the generative drive that is distinct
from aggressive drives and pleasure
drives that exist in all of us
um you know I I'm smiling because a
number of examples of Peace contentment
and Delight while in action come to mind
I mean for me podcasting and in
particular preparing for a podcast
trying to mine the literature and figure
out you know where the gems reside and
where the confusion could could emerge
and all of that brings about such peace
contentment and Delight for me but is
it's anything but passive it's um uh
likewise yesterday I had the experience
of running into a puppy it's been a
while since I've owned a dog and
um dogs are delightful puppies are
particularly by the experience of seeing
you light up when you ran into the puppy
you know I and uh you did and um and I'm
still buzzing from that short
interaction with the puppy downstairs
the waymer and her puppy
um it's just that I don't know why but I
just Delight in in animals of of most
all kinds not a fan of reptile sorry
reptile fans uh so much but it just
drives so much energy from it I felt
like life energy and the the way the
animal is sort of intentionally
scattered is amusing to me as compared
to the dog that he will eventually be
which is going to be more linear in his
thinking like it encapsulates so much of
the other things I love like brain
development Etc anyway I highlight those
examples because
um there's nothing passive about it it's
pure delight and joy for me
um
and it intersects with other Delights
and joys and I think that
um as you describe agency and gratitude
peace contentment and Delight in these
generative forces
um as well as other forces that exist in
us I think it's really critical that uh
people understand that you know these
are not states that you sit down and and
place yourself into although perhaps one
could through uh reflection or
meditation or waking up from a really
great night's sleep things of that sort
but that um these are things that we can
find ourselves Awash in if we are doing
the right things and those things can
oftentimes be very challenging
um so assuming I understand the way the
model is spelled out correctly
um I'm more and more delighted at the
fact that this is not just accessible in
one domain but is accessible in many
many different domains for everybody
right this is not something unique to my
experience even though I give examples
from my own life but um that we really
all do have access to this if we're
looking in those cupboards those 10
cupboards and asking the right questions
and and to maybe comment even a little
further on the experience of of you and
the dog right so so it was a an
experience of delight right and and you
enjoyed it and it brought a sense of
peace and contentment like all of that
happens right think about what that's
linked to like I believe there's a
strong sense of agency in you that you
are enacting there's a strong gratitude
in you that you're enacting you're
you're handling your life in a way and
and also for all of us good things
always come with Good Fortune but but it
comes with our strivings and our
achievements that you're in a place to
Delight in that right if you're unhappy
like I don't like what I'm doing I'm I'm
angry I'm frustrated right then there's
no room in you to to find the Delight
right and the Delight that you find is
also very much linked to the generative
drive right it makes me think of how you
you loved and nurtured Costello right so
you have it in you to love and nurture a
dog and you have done that in a really
wonderful way and that generative Drive
is part parcel of the Delight you feel
when you see a dog because you love dogs
and you think about nurturing and it all
comes together the the the agency and
the Gratitude expressed as verbs puts
you in a position to have that sense of
delight which is so intertwined with
your generative drive with a sense of
caretaking a sense of creating the the
Beyond self because although you enjoyed
and loved Casello you enjoyed and loved
his happiness right so it all comes
together and I think it's interesting
because in some ways it's a simple
example but like that's life you know
life has its its big moments but so much
of our lives are the smaller moments
that link together and I think that
smaller moment it becomes a big example
I appreciate that you mentioned Costello
for listeners of this podcast that have
tuned into early episodes Costello was
the source of the the background snoring
for those of you that haven't you can go
check he's a was a 90 pound English
Bulldog Mastiff who um who had many
skills um the best of which was snoring
um so in addition to the generative
Drive which is something that we
certainly want to talk more about today
you mentioned these other drives
aggressive drives and pleasure drives
and much of what we're talking about
today is going to be where people can go
wrong or where people struggle we are
also of course going to go deeply into
where people succeed and in particular
where people can ask questions of
themselves
um in particular what is working
for them and why as a route to
understanding how to sift through those
cupboards and understand what's not
working and why and come up with real
actionable answers and and then the
ability to move forward so if if you
would could you tell us a little bit
more about drives generally like like
you know when I hear drives I I can't
help as a neuroscientist but default
okay the dopamine circuit or the the
endogenous opioid circuit or the
serotonergic circuit but you know how do
you conceptualize drives within us and
and then perhaps you could tell us what
the nature of aggressive drives and
pleasure drives and generative drives
so that the concept of a drive the
definition of a drive is is something
that's intrinsic to humans so we could
look at it as a motivation right I mean
we don't just lie on the ground and do
nothing until we passively die right so
something is going on inside of us that
is driving us to do something other than
that and historically the thinking in
the field arising from early
psychodynamic principles of the the the
theory in the field that has really
dominated the field either directly or
indirectly in so many ways has been that
there are two drives within us that
there there's aggression and pleasure
and again these are just words right so
we could apply Many Many Words which is
why of course we want to Define what
that means right so aggression even
though we're using that word for it
because the word for it is commonly used
right but it means it means sort of
forward
active engagement right so so a good
healthy amount of aggression using that
word for the drive would be a strong
sense of agency right so so too little
aggression can be a problem right then
the person isn't bringing themselves to
Bear right so there's too little in the
way of self-determination
um forward movement empowerment agency
right and and in the same way too much
of this drive becomes actual aggression
so you know the idea that I want more
and if I can't get it in in certain ways
I'll just take it right so so that so it
starts to become you know what we more
map to the word aggression which which
would be something negative in most
cases like a desire or a tendency to
harm
is that sure we as aggressive drives get
higher which you see why they're in us
because let's say we're defending
ourselves or or you're defending a
family member right or or like an entire
family right then it makes sense to have
high levels of aggression if like your
family is threatened right so so those
drives are in us with with at
potentially those high levels for a
reason but we we certainly access very
high levels of aggression without the
the indication of preservation of life
or preservation of safety so so the
thought is that's a drive in us and that
gets us up and off the ground so to
speak right and that the other drive
then is pleasure which again doesn't
just mean that like we we all want to be
hedonists right so so pleasure could be
even the pleasure of relief and safety
right like we're like you know we're all
back in the cave together and we roll
the stone in front of the door ah we're
safe you know throughout human
development you know pleasure comes in a
lot of ways it can come to the pleasure
of food or other people you know
friendship romance sex there are a lot
of ways we can achieve pleasure it can
be relief of things that are unpleasant
you know relief of pain but there's a
drive towards this in humans which again
really does make sense and and too
little of it again can be problematic
because the person then isn't motivated
to sort of seek things because they're
not anticipating or don't receive
gratification and too much of a drive
for pleasure can also create problems so
so we can kind of see how these two
drives like okay they get us up and off
the ground so to speak but the question
is do they explain everything right and
it's a very important question because
if they explain everything then
there's not really there's not room for
behaviors and choices that are beyond
the self right there's not an
explanation for the person who I'll give
you an example of uh a person I've taken
care of who's this is a very strong
swimmer you know knows how to swim and
swim throughout his life who was in a
place I saw video of it where there had
been a hurricane and the waves were so
frightening you know they were just huge
this huge Surf and there were people who
who had gotten dragged out and they just
see him he runs into the water right he
runs in and he goes and and he was
really at risk he needed to be saved
himself but he saved them and I do not
believe you can explain that through
these drives I don't think you can say
well that was he was aggressive he he
wanted to go and do something you know
that was imposing himself on the world
or he got pleasure in thinking ah I'm
strong enough to go do this I mean I
think we're really gyrating you know
we're contorting ourselves right in
order to explain it that way if we think
there's a goodness in that man's heart
like I know there's a goodness in that
man so I know him right and and that
goodness seizes him in the moment and
you know he knows that maybe he can save
them maybe he can he's not sure but
maybe he can so the next thing you know
he's in the water and I think things
like the love and nurturing of of other
people you know of children love and
nurturing of animals of plants right
like there are things inside of us that
we can't explain with those two drives
and and I think they have led to a very
sort of Darker way of just conceiving of
humans you know I I think it's a reason
why now you know you look at us in the
in the modern day and age we comment
humans through the lens of pathology
right I mean there's a very very thick
book that if if a person is assessing
another person you know is thinking
about like okay what numbers in that
book apply right which is like that's
not the way to go about understanding
humans and I think if we just think
there are those two drives we're not
doing Justice to humans right one I
think it's not true I think it's evident
that it's not true and then if we're
framing it in a way that's not true we
are not appropriately respectful of
humans and if we come from what I
believe to be the truth that there is a
generative Drive-In it's a drive for the
Beyond self a drive to make things
better whether it has anything really
directly to do with me or not and as
with the other drives you know there can
be more or less in people a combination
of Nature and nurture you know what what
genetically is in us a predisposition
you know based upon the genetic lineage
that comes down to us and the
recombination and now we're a unique
person with a unique set of drives but
they are impacted by the genetics and
then they're impacted by life experience
and more strongly formative life
experience right so the younger the
person the sort of deeper the impact of
events they have nurturing versus abuse
right on the the array on the relative
weighting of drives within people but
ultimately we get to these three drives
and how they're functioning in a person
being a way of understanding and
assessing like how
healthier not healthy the person is and
then we look back to those ten cupboards
right for the answers if we're finding
things that we don't like these those
drives are out of balance and and here
are the problems they're causing so very
very concrete issues right of problems
in people's lives we can look and see
where is that out of balance and if it's
out of balance there's something in
those pillars that are not in the right
place we can then go back and look in
all those cupboards for like Oh Where Do
We dig to find the answer right we learn
things we we bring things more into
balance right so so the pillars are in a
healthier place and then what sits on
top of it is you use the word geyser
right the geyser that then comes up and
floats everything on top of it can do
that in a in a healthy way
yeah during episode one we touched on
some of the similarities between
understanding the self and building
towards a healthy
or healthiest version of self where
agency and gratitude are these states
that are being expressed and one of the
themes there was this idea you know
people perhaps want to be healthy so
that they live a long time but
presumably they also want to be healthy
so that they can walk up flights of
stairs pick up their kids move objects
not get injured perhaps even do sport or
um and of course some people want to be
healthy for aesthetic reasons as well
and if we were having a discussion about
physical health we could address the
major pillars there which are were items
within the cupboard like
um you know most people want some
ability to have endurance or stamina to
walk some distance or maybe even run
some distance uh as I mentioned before
walk up a flight of stairs have some
strength some degree of flexibility
certainly some Mobility maybe even
Dynamic Mobility Etc and in order to
address those or improve upon those they
could look in those covers and say well
how much you know running swimming you
know long form cardiovascular exercise
am I doing per week how many steps am I
taking per day uh how many times a week
do I lift objects that are slightly
heavier than is comfortable for me to
lift Etc it's a very tangible very
concrete here you're making the the
psyche and the and and the self and
mental health
very much concrete in some of the same
way saying there are 10 cupboards that
one can look in and these drives as you
refer to them as uh generative Drive
aggressive drive and pleasure Drive
um you'll probably tell us in a few
minutes can be expressed to varying
degrees in different people and how that
shows up and what that looks like and I
just want to frame this in people's
minds as very similar to addressing
whether or not okay if somebody can run
very long distances but they're always
eight you know uh having aches and pains
or they they feel weak or they are weak
you know there are good reasons for that
they're over emphasizing one form of
exercise the expression is more along
the lines of endurance and stamina not
strength
um or vice versa the the power lifter
who can you know lift you know 750
pounds from the floor in a deadlift but
walks up two flights of stairs and is
you know belly breathing and has to stop
at the top of the stairs you know it's
it's obvious in the Physical Realm it's
slightly more cryptic or more cryptic in
the psychological realm but here it's
becoming concrete for us so I think it's
it's very interesting and very ironic
right so the field that I'm in the field
of Psychiatry has historically wanted to
be sort of part of the rest of medicine
or like the rest of medicine and and
what I believe it's ended up doing is
glorifying a taxonomy right glorifying a
category uh mechanism of understanding
human beings so in the way that that if
okay if I'm a practicing general
medicine and you come in and you're
congested and and I determine like oh
you have you have bacterial sinusitis
right so so now I've made a diagnosis
and now the I I know what I'm going to
do about that right so so that okay I'm
going to prescribe an antibiotic now the
thought comes in of like what antibiotic
right but the identify sinusitis now you
need an antibiotic is like kind of how
medicine works right so the thought was
Psychiatry is going to categorize
everything right so we'd say okay listen
to you like ah I know your number or
your numbers right and then once I've
given you the numbers now I know what to
do I prescribe this medicine that
medicine these many sessions of a
certain kind of psychotherapy and like
that doesn't work right it doesn't work
in mental health it may I mean it's not
that it never works but if you're going
to try and understand people like it's
different a problem of self like if I
have a lack of confidence in one area of
life and not in others right that's a
significant issue it is not like
bacterial sinusitis where then you know
okay arrow goes to prescribe antibiotic
and I think what is ironic is that
this
route of approach right actually does
bring Psychiatry mental health into line
with the rest of medicine right which is
why you you can make that parallel and
you know it fits well right when you're
making the parallel to physical health
and to I want to be healthy okay what
are the components of that what am I
doing to achieve that if something's not
the way I want let me go back and look
at those components I mean it may be
because it's more tangible it's sort of
essentially easier to comprehend right
because it's more it's more concrete but
but I don't in a sense see it as cryptic
just less obvious right but if we go and
we look at it and we say oh like that
really makes sense right and and in a
sense it makes sense that it makes sense
right if there's a mechanism of
understanding that applies to lots and
lots of things that are more concrete
why would a similar kind of mechanism
like understand what the components are
understand what's built on top of them
like this I believe is how Psychiatry
actually fits with the rest of medicine
not by glorifying a taxonomy but by
coming through the lens of understanding
yeah I couldn't agree more and I I think
that uh what's so reassuring is that
both in terms of creating physical
health across the various domains of you
know heart health lung Health endurance
strength Etc cognitive Health as well as
mental health is verbs you know it comes
back to action items that we each and
all should engage in in order to arrive
at the states and
you know ways of being that we all want
to be in right we want to feel healthy
look healthy you know Etc we want to
um be happy right I I know very few
people who don't want to be happy I mean
certainly if there are people who give
up but we'll talk about that today and
and routes out of that but at the end of
the day it's all about looking in those
bins asking specific questions and then
moving forward in specific actions to
get to the place of empowerment humility
agency gratitude peace contentment
Delight Etc
um as opposed to
um
simply using words and understanding to
arrive at insight and then stopping
there and expecting everything to change
and I think that's where a lot of people
are confused about psychology therapy
and Psychiatry and um and as you
mentioned Psychiatry has its own
um uh Shadows if you will within it
where the the use of of drugs which
certainly can be very useful even
life-saving absolutely oftentimes is is
seen as a um a fix-all that um somehow
could reorder everything within the
cupboards and make the recipe just right
when in fact so we'll talk about today
that that is um generally not the best
route but again with the understanding
that drugs can be very powerful tools
play a role yeah right but it's
important we understand what role is
appropriate for them and that's where we
often go astray
I'd like to take a brief break and
acknowledge one of our sponsors ag-1 ag1
is a vitamin mineral probiotic drink
that meets all of your foundational
nutrition needs I started taking ag-1
way back in 2012. so I'm delighted that
they're sponsoring the podcast the
reason I started taking ag1 and the
reason I still take ag1 once or
generally twice per day is that it's the
easiest way for me to ensure that I'm
getting all of the vitamins minerals
probiotics and fiber that I need in my
diet now of course it's essential to get
proper nutrition from Whole Foods but
most people including myself find it
hard to get enough servings of fruits
and vegetables each day and especially
to get enough prebiotics and probiotics
to ensure gut health as you may know
your gut contains trillions of little
microbiota the so-called gut microbiome
which establishes critical connections
with other organs of your body to
enhance brain health as well as to
support your immune system and other
aspects that relate to mental and
physical health one of the most common
questions I get is if you were to take
Just One supplement which supplement
would that be and May my answer is
always ag1 because by taking ag1 I'm
able to ensure that I'm getting all of
the vitamins minerals and probiotics
that I need to enhance my mental health
physical health and performance if you'd
like to try ag1 go to drinkag1.com
huberman to claim a special offer
they'll give you five free travel packs
and they'll give you a year's supply of
vitamin D3 K2 again that's drink ag1.com
huberman to claim this special offer so
as we move forward here in defining and
helping people gain for lack of a better
word agency over their own mental health
and self-understanding and defining for
them what what action items to take you
know I think I'd like to ask you about
some of the things that I observe in the
world and hear a lot about in particular
from the audience of this podcast
you know
um it's obvious to me that people vary
in terms of their level of aggressive
Drive pleasure drive and presumably
generative drive as well
um
one common question is
how do I become more motivated right you
know um and of course that opens up a
bunch of other questions like are people
afraid of failure and that's why they're
not motivated are people afraid of
success is that why they're not
motivated is there some underlying
childhood trauma or unconscious process
uh that's driving that fear
um and so on but if we were to take the
psychiatrist perspective your
perspective if someone comes to you and
says you know I
you know I just don't really feel like
trying it's you know school's hard
school loans are you know are excessive
which is true by the way
um you know it's not even clear that
with a degree I can do much you know or
I had a series of failures in in the
work domain or in the relationship
domain and and they're just feeling
weighed down as if it's not worth trying
um you know what does that tell you in
terms of where to look and and what does
that tell you in terms of their drives I
mean do we conclude something about
their innate level of aggressive Drive
um or their pleasure drive or their
generative Drive I mean I think there
are many such people out there and then
we'll consider some other um kind of
phenotypic examples right so it's a
great example because sort of
any good clinician right could could
hear that story and then and have
thoughts about it right that that could
and would hopefully be helpful right
without necessarily referring to drives
right so so I think you can anchor any
set of Assessments any evaluation any
attempted understanding two drives right
but but it doesn't have to be that way
so for example you might ask that person
more questions about what they're doing
how they spend their time because you're
telling me about someone who's not in
getting enjoyment or gratification out
of anything right and and that then
Becomes Of Interest to me right is is
there is there something this person
does enjoy right or something they'd
rather be doing like did they did they
go to college and take on a bunch of
loans because they thought that was
better because they thought they were
going to do something that now they
actually don't want to do right or that
opportunity isn't there and now they're
frustrated like what is inside this
person that might seem different than
that and again the answers could be
complicated it could be maybe that
person enjoys what they're doing but the
cost of living where they are is so high
that they still feel miserable there's a
sense of privation and then that gets
back mapped to like I'm not getting any
pleasure out of anything right so the
answer could be as simple as you
strategize with the person of you know
for example does a person like that move
you know move to a different area so so
like there's so many ways of looking at
this in so many ways of understanding
this but you're describing someone to me
who who is kind of really complaining
that nothing is feeling good right
nothing's providing a sense of uh of
enjoyment or of pleasure right so I
would probably be interested in that
first and think maybe the the pleasure
Drive is higher than what's being
fulfilled right maybe the pleasure Drive
is is low and that's an issue in and of
itself we sort of learned those things
right maybe the aggressive Drive is low
and you know if that person just put a
little more energy into it right like
they could be in a different place right
so you're trying to help the person
understand themselves so that you can
make change and again that understanding
doesn't have to be anchored to to the
drives but I do believe the drives are
at the root of all understanding because
if you sit with that person and you talk
to that person then you're going to be
able to understand what is out of
balance right either in the the actual
array of the drives or in how they're
being being experienced because again if
you have a high pleasure drive to for
example and it's not gratified right
like that represents a problem right
yeah what what about people who can
experience some pleasure or can keep
busy say for instance on social media or
playing video games and I should also
say perhaps it's bringing them to a
place of Peace contentment and Delight
but in some sense it's not really
generative right it you know I'm not
going to cast judgment and say say that
video games and social media are all a
waste of time I mean I'm on social media
trying to provide value to people and
learnings and um and I derive value in
learnings from other accounts as well
but you know there are these um
Milestones if you will in life I mean
not that everyone has to you know go to
college and and get married and have a
family I mean there are a lot of
different paths through life that I
would consider successful
but in some sense we you know there are
Milestones like we want to move forward
there's this phenomena nowadays of a lot
of
um young people and so-called Failure to
Launch like they're not leaving home or
they're not finding a vocation they're
not they're not feeling as if they're
good at anything
um or they have the sense that unless
you're going to be a Prof you know like
top one percent in something it's not
worth trying but they can still find uh
you know what most people describe as
Pleasures like they might they enjoy
food
um maybe a little too much they enjoy uh
alcohol maybe a little too much they
enjoy social media or video games maybe
a little too much I say a little too
much because it it's providing more or
less a a sink or or a reservoir for
their aggressive and pleasure drives
that's not moving them forward in the
standard Milestones of life
um I I hear about that a lot I I see
that a lot
um you know so it's a slightly more um
complex uh phenotype than described
before is just simply the a motivated or
non-motivated person but you know what
does one you know what do you think of
of that of the phenotype I just
described again because we're unique
right each person is unique or the we
fit categories right so there are
categories a person there could fit that
could be different from what I'm saying
right but I think
most people just say on balance right
what's what is most prominent right I
think what is most prominent in that
situation is there's something out of
balance in the generative drive right
and what you see a lot of times is the
person is a generative Drive in them
that's higher than their ability to to
realize that drive the generative drive
then is frustrated so I'll give an
example it's a real true story of a
person who worked very very hard gone to
school for a long time and it achieved a
very high paying job and like that was
the goal right it's a prestigious job
it's a high-paying job and the person
for a while was doing quite well at it
and you know things went
now relatively rapidly in a negative
directions maybe for a little while the
person's doing okay then the person
becomes very negligent of themselves and
their environment when they're not at
the job so you know the the house is a
mess things are dirty the person is
wasting time with things so this is a
person who enjoys it wasn't exactly
video games I would say let's say it
could have been right well it enjoys
them to a certain degree and can really
gain pleasure and feel good about the
time spent right but start spending too
much time right now what was pleasurable
starts becoming a distraction mechanism
right and then what that transition to
was overuse of alcohol right so now you
have either something that is actually
destructive and was negative to job
performance right towards the person
this wasn't a person who was drinking a
lot before and this is a person who is
miserable when they were drinking or
they were sort of wasting their time
right and we're aware of all of this
well
it was a very clear problem which is
that that person
had no interest in what they were doing
none whatsoever it felt like the
majority of waking hours were spent
in an automaton-like way but being awake
and aware of the tedium of it the
frustration of it the professional side
so they especially had very little uh
intrinsic curiosity or desire to do the
job that they were successfully doing
right which comes out only after
exploration because it seems like what's
going on with this person like this
person has a good job and their life was
going really really well and and they're
doing well financially and you know is
this person trying to now you know
overly indulge themselves right like is
that why they're drinking what's going
on right and what you you feel is that
this person has a strong generative
drive and it was it meant one little bit
by what he was doing which was creating
such frustration inside that the person
was either taking himself online or
doing something that was punitive and
self-injurious and like this is a real
story The the person exchanged that job
for a job that paid a tenth of what the
job they had paid and the change in the
person's life was amazing like I didn't
know this guy could smile right he
became happy he loved what he was doing
he sold the larger house bought a
smaller house kept it beautifully like
he was happy right that's what he needed
to be happy because then the generative
Drive in him he loved what he was doing
right gets enacted it gets expressed and
then other other things can come then
into line right he's not being over
aggressive towards himself and drinking
too much you know because he's saying oh
to hell with you to the world around him
and to himself right he's not taking
something that serves a purpose in his
life like again if the example had been
video games it would be like yeah great
you enjoy doing that x amount of time
and like go do that and get
gratification from it as opposed to then
over relying on it and then it's not
providing gratification it becomes a
distraction so those things came back
into balance in his life but there had
to be the understanding and I think
there's a lot of that in people who have
a generative Drive in them that they
feel is frustrated by a world around
them that isn't cooperating now do I
think we can understand that and change
that in the vast majority of people who
are in that place yes but it has to be
looked at first right because when it's
not always that it's just that a lot of
the time right so it has to be
understood what is it in that person and
then how do you go back to those pillars
and look at what's going on that the
person is in that place because the
world can bring us a lot of difficulties
right and that person who now has
saddled with a lot more loans than they
expect like I have tremendous compassion
for that and sympathy for that like
that's real right so people can be up
against a lot of things and that's just
one of them right but it doesn't mean
that life can't be okay
right it doesn't mean that but the
person has to feel that there's some way
they have to understand enough about
themselves is okay this is what this is
and I kind of see what this is and why
and how I'm here and from there I can
start to plot a route to something that
is better because yes we have our
difficulties and we can have a lot of
them right but it's for the vast
majority of us it's not like they're not
surmountable we have to just understand
them and let's say if that person goes
and so I'm going to get some help and
they go and someone says okay wait you
get 10 sessions of cognitive behavioral
therapy and you're trying like how can
that person think differently than
they'll feel differently and look
cognitive behavioral therapy has its
place right but it's not going to solve
that right like that person needs to
understand something about themselves
not redirect their thoughts to better
places right so if the person gets a
reflex because that reflex works well
for the system right it reflux works
well for the system that's treating that
person for the medical system the
insurance system that person is in
helping one bit right and maybe a
medicine can help right maybe a medicine
helps to just take down the anxiety and
the tension in the person then the
person can sort of think more about it
and and truly medicine did help this
person because the idea of leaving the
job I'm leaving the prestige I'm leaving
the money is that okay to do like it
generated a lot of anxiety and it helped
to kind of bring the temperature down a
little bit of that so that he could
think about it engage in therapy
ultimately navigate to where he wanted
to be then we could back away from the
medicine so like medicine has a role but
if he just got medicine I mean what are
the possibilities what are the odds of
that helping like zero right because
it's not going to make the answers
Unless somehow the person feels a little
bit better and figures it out on their
own it's not how it works right so
medicine
has its place but a a kind of therapy
that recognizes the limitations of
medicine in most situations and is
designed to really help the person
understand like that's what we need
well the example you gave is a
spectacular one because as you mentioned
medication had its place uh perhaps even
redirection of thought in some sense had
its place because as I recall it under
the the pillar of function of self one
of the the key items uh is salience you
know what we pay attention to internally
or externally what our internal
narratives are but
um in staying with the example of this
individual again as a as a phenotypic uh
example for everybody to to learn
something from
the
asking of better questions about oneself
is really what leads to the
understanding so that like better forms
of inquiry right to me the these are the
these better forms of inquiry uh better
questions are really the uh
cardiovascular exercise the strength
training the flexibility training the
mobility training coordination training
of physical health just translate to to
mental health right it's so it's so
interesting right because if you think
about it in the example I gave both the
therapy part from through the system
right the the CBT has a place right and
the medicine part also had a play so
both of those things have their role but
if we build the whole story of like this
is what this is and this is how you're
going to be helped around those things
we don't help that person at all in fact
we ultimately if you take on balance you
take all comers we end up doing harm
well in some ways if we stay with the um
the analogy of physical health it would
be like the person who wants to get in
shape and then they get a I'm not
picking on Peloton as a brand which is a
stationary bike and they they pedal
every morning and they lose weight their
blood pressure goes down they're doing
better but then at some point if we we
know for with certainty that if you just
do the same form of exercise over and
over again like sooner or later you're
going to get overuse injuries so then
there's like the lower back piece and
another piece and and you become out of
balance right there's just but you know
I guess this is stealing from the Lance
Armstrong book uh but it's not about the
bike right I mean that you know it's not
about the bike it's about the elevation
of heart rate it's about the um whatever
other healthy activities go along with
exercising first thing in the morning
and all the things that you're not doing
as a consequence of exercising in the
morning
um so it seems to me that these these uh
better lines of inquiry is the path to
better mental health a better life
um that sit under these pillars of
structure or self-function of self are
really the key so in this example right
the parallel that you made is even more
dramatic right it wouldn't be the the
stationary bike right because the
stationary bike is achieving a lot of
ends right it would be more like telling
the person you know you should walk more
briskly when you're going upstairs right
like that's a good idea but that's not
going to make the change right so the
idea that some CBT some medicine makes
sense it's more like that right it's not
that walking more briskly up the stairs
isn't a good thing it's that we can't
build the story around your whole health
is going to change based upon that and
then that's that's a problem then if the
person thinks just walk more briskly up
the stairs and you'll be healthier
because when it doesn't work now they've
failed right and this gets used a lot in
mental if that person failed this
therapy failed that medicine right and I
think it's so also ironic because that's
often what the person internalizes well
they failed because we set them up 100
for failure right because we took things
things that have their role at least
potentially have their role and we built
the whole story around them because that
story is convenient for the systems that
are providing the care it's Pro it's
convenient for the Health Care Systems
it's convenient for the insurers CBT
packages very nicely and you could see
how if you start changing thoughts and
how they make you feel like you know you
can get some movement on the surface
even if there's no movement underneath
right and again I'm not saying CBT is
bad but to see it as the whole answer
guarantees failure in so many situations
same thing with the medicine if you
build the whole story just because it's
convenient and and by and large
medicines are cheaper than people right
so so you can prescribe medicines very
reflexively psychiatrists with 15
minutes with a patient that they can't
then see back for a couple of months
like how does that go well the answer is
it only goes well the way a broken clock
is right a couple of times you know
twice twice a day right I mean some look
sometimes it goes well where it just
somehow it works out and that person can
do a little bit of therapy in 15 minutes
and choose the right medicines but by
and large we do those things because
they're convenient for the systems even
though that's why like people don't get
better like like we think they would
that's why they stay in systems that's
why they come in and out of emergency
rooms that's why they're not able to
stop the drugs that end up you know only
being stopped when the person dies like
this happens all the time and we don't
stop it because we're coming from a
perspective that is so limited that's
not saying let's take a step back and
look can we really like help someone can
we really help that person understand
can we help that person make change
which ultimately would be of course so
much better for the person and so much
better for society but is also better if
we just look at bottom line dollars and
cents right because the short-term view
of it is cheaper today to have a
psychiatrist at a 15-minute appointment
reflexively prescribed in medicine that
is cheaper today is that cheaper across
time when that person is utilizing more
resources or they're in and out of
emergency rooms it's so short-sighted
with which fits with many ways and how
our society works right that we want
gratification we want gratification
rapidly that's why a person would accept
that their problems could be changed by
a medicine right we're kind of
conditioned that way well and then of
course there's the the cost we don't see
which is that person doesn't get the
opportunity to express their generative
drive and so the the and the the
consequence of that is incalculable
right yes and if we take a step back and
we look at that I think that what we
will see is that we have it's not quite
like painted ourselves into a corner but
it's like you know the idea that if
there's a beautiful tapestry that's the
size of the wall right that you can see
that only standing back from it right I
mean this goes back you know I think a
couple thousand years right this this
sort of thought and idea but if you come
up too close to it then you can't see
what it means anymore and we're up so
close to it that we're thinking well
okay how could one parameter change and
you know can can this person get a
15-minute visit sooner rather than later
or how about this medicine instead of
that and then it's like our noses are
right up against the tapestry and we
don't see that we're not doing right by
individual people a lot of the time and
we're not doing right by society which
then if you stop and think about it
we're not doing right by us because any
one of us could be in that position and
many of us have been in that position
being on the other side of things and
really needing help and needing to
understand so any of us can be there so
if we're failing a lot of individual
people and we're failing the society it
doesn't matter who we are listening to
this like ultimately we're failing
ourselves
I'd like to take a brief break and
acknowledge our sponsor eight sleep
eight sleep makes Smart mattress covers
with cooling Heating and sleep tracking
capacity I've spoken many times before
on this podcast and elsewhere about the
fact that getting a quality night's
sleep on a regular basis is the
foundation of mental health physical
health and performance when we're
sleeping well everything goes better
when we are not sleeping well or enough
everything in terms of mental health
physical health and performance gets far
worse very quickly one of the key things
to getting a great night's sleep is to
control the temperature of your sleeping
environment and that's because in order
to fall and stay deeply asleep you need
your core body temperature to drop by
about one to three degrees and in order
to wake up feeling refreshed you need
your core body temperature to increase
by about one to three degrees that all
becomes very easy when using an eight
sleep mattress cover because it allows
you to program the temperature of your
sleeping environment at the beginning
middle and towards the end of your night
when you wake up I started sleeping on
an eight-sleep mattress cover over two
years ago and it immediately and
persistently improved the quality and
depth of my sleep and as a constant
sequence I wake up feeling far more
refreshed I have enhanced mood focus and
alertness throughout the day if you'd
like to try eight sleep you can go to
eightsleep.com huberman to save up to
150 off their pod 3 cover H sleep
currently ships in the USA Canada UK
select countries in the EU and Australia
again that's eightsleep.com huberman
let's therefore talk about what does
work you know and again placing on the
Shelf the the fact that medications can
help and CBT cognitive behavioral
therapy can't help but it they are just
but two components of a much larger
picture
the map that we described briefly at the
beginning of today's episode and that is
by the way available as a downloadable
PDF in the show note captions if people
want to look at it visually and that was
described in a lot of detail in episode
one which I hope people will take the
time to listen to because it's so rich
with depth of understanding and I'm
certain everyone will learn a ton about
themselves and others simply by
listening to your words I'm absolutely
certain of that
that map provides
essentially a description of the bins
the cupboards to look in uh to arrive at
better answers and and even the sorts of
questions that one might ask
if we could just talk about that in the
context of the example that you gave of
this person who made this really
incredible choice to move away from this
higher paying job
um you know they were over indulging in
in certain maladaptive behaviors and
again we will use this example but
um this example is but one of
an infinite number of examples that we
could use of a person who's you know in
a struggle right they're doing something
that's not working for them and they're
also not doing things that they know
they ought to be doing okay
um this is important for people to to
understand because
um they're going to be people out there
that are thinking oh like this poor guy
like he's making tons of money poor him
you know but you know he was
experiencing deep
is miserable lack of satisfaction so it
could it could have been the reverse
example like the person isn't in a job
that that brings about enough wealth for
them to to thrive right because there
are Financial realities to life
um so it's just one example right right
but it's a good one I think because the
person left the money right so it's like
what would make you leave that right and
he said well what would make you leave
that is if you are miserable in the
situation with that and you're happy in
the situation without it right so it's
about leaving misery and and finding
happiness that's so if you'd be willing
to share with us a little bit of your
mindset during those sessions meaning
the sorts of questions you asked him
about the structure of his self or to
reveal the structure of himself and the
function of his self that allowed the
both of you to eventually set him down
this um far better course you know
what's better than moving away from
frustration and over indulgence and
maladaptive Behavior to deep
satisfaction peace contentment and
delight and to become a generative human
being right so we can look in each of
those 10 cabinets right so let's say we
look in the unconscious mind cabinet
there's not much there right when the
person was growing up it was very clear
that having more money and having a job
that impressed people was was an
important thing he internalizes some of
it so some of it's unconscious but by
and large she's aware of it and that was
revealed to you how he you know you
would ask him a question about
um you know like tell me about your
upbringing and he would say yeah like
you know money was important in my
family but we I always felt like we had
you know enough whether he wasn't super
wealthy but had enough and so when you
say there wasn't a lot there do you mean
that there was no kind of like x marks
the spot or like like blinking red light
like whoa there's something really in
his unconscious mind that's in his way
is it do I have that right well more
because it was conscious right so so he
was aware that it was very much like
beat into him right like this is the
only way to be okay right is to have a
prestigious job that makes a lot of
money right but he's aware of it if he
weren't aware of it we have to bring
that to light right but he was aware
he's like look it has a big impact on me
it makes it hard to step away like I
know I don't really care that much about
the money but I also kind of do you know
sure I would say money can't buy
happiness but it certainly can buffer
certain stressors in life I mean nobody
you know sometimes you hear people who
have a lot of money saying like money
can't buy happiness because you know a
lot of miserable rich people but it's
like you know uh it's very different to
have a two night nurses to take care of
a baby than to be the person who has to
stay up all night taking care of a kid
especially or a single mother versus a a
mother that has a partner who's willing
to pitch in you know you just can't
compare and why that's that's absolutely
true in this case we're just looking at
money as money like as an end point
right the idea that no matter no matter
what right how how secure and safe like
is more money better right and he had an
intrinsic overvalue of that right so it
made it harder to step away from it
because he he was overvaluing it he knew
he was overvaluing it just in and of
itself not even for what it gets you
right but for the psychological meaning
of it right then we look at his
defensive structures if we look in that
cupboard you see that they've they've
really shifted right they shifted from
healthy places now they're sort of
Twisted and distorted and he's doing a
lot of denial a lot of avoidance a lot
of rationalization right he's enacting a
lot of aggression towards himself and
he's progressed he's he's doing a lot of
projecting right he's he's harming
himself with the alcohol he's punishing
himself like so his defensive structure
it can be healthy we know that because
it was healthier right but then we see
that it is so Twisted so we learn a lot
from that right a lot is conscious in
this person the defensive structure can
be healthy because it was healthy but
eventually it was healthy well it was
healthy before I see it was healthy
before so you know that it can be
healthy again right he has it in him to
have healthy defenses they just started
getting away from him as he felt less
and less satisfied with his job and more
and more angry with himself and more
miserable um this is a really key point
for me and everyone else to understand
you know throughout the years of
high school and college and friends and
things of that sort I would hear this
like I used to be really good at Fitness
or I used to you know if I had a dollar
for every time someone said you know you
should have seen me in high school you
know like like the person who lets
themselves go and and arguably is very
busy with with professional duties and
family duties and you can understand why
their time is more compressed
um than it was when they were in high
school but nonetheless you know you hear
these sorts of things all the time like
I used to have this sense of like I
could do things or that like things
could work out or that uh and then it's
as if there was a previous version of
themselves that is completely atrophied
and the new version of themselves or the
later version of themselves rather just
simply
like doesn't have access to that anymore
right and that's the impact of trauma
yeah right okay right whether it's big
trauma or it's you know a big event or
it's multiple things like oh the world
this isn't rewarding me I'm trying the
world's not rewarding me I'm trying the
world's not rewarding me then people
become dispirited right demoralized
right so so it's the trauma of that that
takes away the the sense of self the
sense of agency like I thought I could
do things before now I don't think I can
do things right but but nothing has
really changed in me I mean that's
that's a problem right and it's a
problem the vast majority of times it's
born of trauma does that um necessarily
mean Early Childhood trauma or
um I suppose it could be later life
trauma I mean one of the things that I I
like about what you're saying so much is
that you know
you the psychiatrist is hears I used to
be able to do something well or feel
well and and that's like it sounds like
is a a signal it's really a beacon of
Health that still exists in the person
but that they're out of touch with I
think for
for most people when they think about
themselves or people who talk about how
they used to be functional in some
domain and they're no longer functional
in that domain any longer it sounds as
if like things are fundamentally broken
like like is this of a piece of them
that was that was functioning like
drifted out of their body and left right
but I love the optimism all right
because I think so much of what we're
interested in covering today is not just
what's not working and why but also
what's working and why and what used to
work and why and and the idea that you
know within these cupboards there can be
the discovery of of problems uh clearly
that's why one goes to the cupboards
right as we're defining it but that
um there are a lot of answers there are
there are rest the ingredients for
Success already exist within us right
especially if we know we've had that
ability before right because we know
that we had it before so think about in
this man he he felt that he couldn't
make change like now he's stuck right
like I I got a lot of things done I was
able to get myself into this school and
achieve this and you know and then get
this job like he could do all those
things but now he feels like he can't do
anything to make himself happy so like
we know he could do that he had a strong
sense of agency he does it now right and
and like people often do they feel a
sense of loss like naturally I've had
this happen in myself like it feels like
something's cut out of you and there's
something Hollow I had that thing and
now I don't right hence the I'm broken
I'm hopeless the things that we hear
over and over and over again so think
about the shift in this person to like
what's actually going on which isn't
that hard to discern we just pay
attention to it so that if we run up the
structure of self we say okay not a lot
of it is rooted in the unconscious mind
right there there are problems of
overvaluing certain things but they're
in the conscious mind he knows like in
his household over dinner it was you
know Dad or Mom you know uh being proud
of of some dollar amount that they
didn't achieve so so that narrative
exists and he's like yeah like money was
a big deal in my family kind of thing
right by the way I'm not speaking about
my family but rarely were there
discussions about money there were
discussions about other things of course
but in in this hypothetical and he knows
I'm not a real patient sorry he knows he
overvalues it right he knows it
independent of what money buys and what
he needs and all that he just puts too
much importance in money and he knows
that right so okay their conscious mind
issues he's pretty aware of them and
they're pretty kind of set in him like
those are the issues and they're there
okay we learned that then we go look at
his defensive structure boy that's very
very helpful to talk about wow like you
had a very healthy defensive structure
what were you doing before a lot of
sublimation right could you explain
sublimation yeah take anxiety attention
or something something negative in the
self or there could be negative and you
Channel it towards something positive
right he channeled that energy towards
learning right he channeled some of the
aggressive drive right into a sense of
agency that got achievement so he looked
and said right those you know the the
that um Network right of of defense
mechanisms that comes up out of the
unconscious mind was like looking pretty
good right it was pretty clear light was
coming through it in a you know in a way
that wasn't distorted and now we can
look at wow like that things are pretty
different now right as as he's saying no
it's okay like what do you mean I I
spent 10 hours of my weekend utterly
wasting time and what's wrong with that
right or you know he's rationalizing
even that he likes to drink when he
doesn't because he's so mad at himself
like the defensive structure now is
Twisted right so we can say okay we
that's a big observation right and then
the character structure when we look at
that we find a person who's pretty good
at figuring out and understanding things
and coming right up to the precipice of
change but is a long history of then
difficulty making the change right I
know it and I'm on the verge of it but I
don't I can't bring myself to do it like
that's in his character structure by the
way it's such a common thing I mean
people that know know better know they
know better sometimes you almost have to
wonder whether or not it's like
um it's like a medication in the pocket
like they could take it if they wanted
to that that might even give them some
comfort but they just don't do it they
just don't engage in the proper actions
to move their life from one place to the
next right and if we look then at the
level of strivings like he does know
what he wants like he he wants a feeling
of contempt it's really what he wanted
was a feeling of contentment a feeling
of like I'm taking good care of myself
I'm doing something that's of value I'm
enjoying doing it like he wanted those
things and even when we talked more he
had ideas of what jobs would do that in
the beginning he said he had no idea so
what he really meant
that he said to me but was also saying
to himself is I have no ideas of jobs
that would meet these requirements for
me that pay as much as the one I have
right so but but within him which we got
to where where he knew that there were
jobs that would make him happy he just
had to get over that they were lower
paying so think of what we learn about
that there's nothing lost in this man
there's nothing cut out of him but he's
not damaged he's not hopeless and now he
can understand that you know he that he
understands himself actually pretty well
right and and his conscious mind is
apprehending pretty well what's going on
and where he wants to go but boy as he
hasn't taken good care of himself the
defensive structure gets sort of warped
and then it makes it a lot harder to
take care of yourself it starts making
other problems in life and he starts
like feeling lousy about himself like
maybe I can't do much of anything right
why because work isn't going as well
because he's drinking too much and role
performance goes down right so we can
see that and then you know what's of
most interest there is that there's a
character structure that can come right
up to the precipice but not but not pull
the trigger so to speak on what the
thing the thing the person wants to do
because now we start getting okay an
understanding of what's actually going
on right and then if we look at function
of self let's look in those cabinets too
right to help him be more aware of
there's an eye here like which he was
pretty well aware of but not enough like
there's a person here I'm shepherding
through 24 hours in the day right like I
am an eye and I'm aware of what's going
on inside of me and it can make me happy
or it can make me miserable like let's
let's be more aware of that how did he
go about doing that because I I find
this this first step within addressing
the function of self you know
self-awareness and really understand
that there's a there's a there's an eye
there's a me and I'm moving myself
through life I I find this to be so
interesting and on the one hand kind of
obvious like okay there's a mean like
tangible thing you look in the mirror
you see yourself but
at the same time it's a bit abstract I
think to me and to many people out there
like how does one go about building up a
sense of self in a way that provides
positive agency in the world is it to
tell you know we hear all the time about
these like affirmations and I'm sure
there are people who look at themselves
in the mirror and say you are enough and
these and I'm not making fun of these
people right I actually have my own
internal
um list that I uh tell myself on waking
every morning which has nothing to do
with positive affirmation it's just
actually defining the different roles
that I play I don't know why this is
useful to me but I find it incredibly
useful to me
um it reminds me who I am it also
reminds or it reassures me that I don't
have any dementia yet uh so um I you
know we'll see going forward but
um hopefully not but yeah let's talk
about this this line of inquiry within
the the category of self-awareness that
people can do regardless of whatever
challenges they they might be having or
not having you know what does that look
like and what do you think that
accomplishes at the level of
self-understanding and agency in the
world so one way of looking at that is
and it's not the words I would use but
like what's pervading a person and sort
of set setting the stage right which you
can discern by inquiry so so for example
in this case the person so there's a
person right who would really not think
this is okay right this person taking a
job at 10 of the previous pay and the
job has less Prestige right who's a
person who would be very unhappy about
that and very faulting of that and and
talk to this person my patient through
the lens of it he should feel shame for
that that person's not alive
the person is not alive so one way of
looking at is what Master are you
serving right and a lot of like the
Givens right the automaticity in him was
as if like that person was sort of alive
inside of him really telling him like
how this wasn't okay like he was
fighting that he wasn't aware that hey
that's some other person's voice it was
like he's like I'm very very conflicted
about this actually he wasn't very
conflicted about this when he starts
focusing on the eye like what do I
actually think
what do I actually think I don't I don't
care if I make 90 less like I don't care
my needs are met I put some money away I
want to be happy I'm not conflicted like
so so but in order to get there we have
to look at the eye how much is the eye
at Center Stage right and all that I
don't mean in some way like paying too
much attention to the self but like
we're all acting through the lens of the
eye no matter what we're choosing right
so to be aware of that and do I want to
be impacted by the opinions of this
other person because I can let someone
else's opinions very much I mean we we
all do right very much impact my
thoughts but I want to kind of decide
that do I really value that person's
opinions I don't want them automatically
inside my head telling me how I feel
about myself
I can't tell you how many people I know
come to me in a place of struggle even
though I'm not a clinician and as I
listen to what they're struggling with
it's so clear that they know the best
answer and Route forward but that
they're dealing with some internal
oppressive voice about whether or not
they are a good person or a bad person
whether or not the choice they want to
make is really a good choice at all
sometimes those voices are the voices of
parents
um because you know in these particular
examples or the voices of peers and so I
think if I understand correctly what
what you're talking about is getting
really firmly rooted in who a person is
for themselves and what they really
value and what they what they really
know to be true for themselves and
really trying to not necessarily quiet
those voices but see those voices truly
as other even though they come from with
within their head yeah is that right yes
yes to stop and think what voices do I
want inside so so maybe I want the voice
of
a kind Mentor who still held me to
account you know for a very high
standard right it's a good voice to have
inside of me I have a few of those and
then yeah but what might not be a good
voice is they say a not so kind Mentor
for whom you could never do anything
good enough
that's not so maybe you take part of
that new Leaf part of that but the
earlier and more formative the voices
are the more they're in our head
automatically I think that that man
thought that he was deeply conflicted
absolutely 100 I could tell and it has
he was right like his experience was to
be deeply conflicted but when you go in
and dig
there's actually if you just dig and you
and you get to like okay the eye is
gonna assess this he's he's not
conflicted at all
which is why then if you're coming up
the function of self-ladder and you look
at defense mechanisms in action right
and what's on top of that salience right
now is when it creates an immediacy
right so defense mechanisms in actions
sort of inform the process and say hey
the defenses are shifting to denial
acting out right and that's what sort of
gives us a Time Horizon like these
things this is not going to be okay
right that if we kept down this path
what was very clearly going to happen
you don't have to roll the tape forward
that much to see that he's going to lose
his job right he's going to feel very
ashamed of that like a bunch of negative
things are going to happen so it helps
the person apprehend that like there's
something going on here like I'm
changing right because like in some way
I'm thinking now that it's okay that I'm
wasting 10 hours on something that I
could really enjoy if I spent 90 minutes
on it like like whoa I'm kind of losing
a little bit of perspective there right
so it adds a sense like it frames the
situation right and the salience of it
could you elaborate a little bit on um
this defense mechanism in action of
acting out you know I think uh we
covered in episode one and I'm sure
we'll come up several times more during
today's discussion about things like
denial projection displacement
etc those defense mechanisms
um seemed at their own intrinsic
definition but you know acting out is
something that we hear more and more
about these days like they're acting out
uh like what is acting out
um is it is it acting out of some
conflict
um is it trying to uh you know
demolish a struggle by by going and
doing something else we can think of it
as by and large an unhealthy
manifestation of a lot of aggression
which could be a very high aggressive
drive or an aggressive drive that's not
too high but is then furthered its
powers furthered by a negative situation
right say like this one right because
they're acting out what was going on
here inside of this person is he was
very very mad right and this isn't a
person who who expressed a lot of anger
right so we're at outlets for it right
he wasn't going and running 10 miles all
right hey this was all inside of him he
wasn't getting it out in one way or
another so what he starts doing is he
starts acting out the anger now he's
angry at the world around him because
he's unhappy in it and it's not giving
him more choices now of course this is
about him and not the world around him
right but but he's feeling an anger
towards the world that won't cooperate
right and he's angry towards himself
right because like he can't make himself
happy like look at all this look at all
that he did and look how miserable he is
right so a way of acting out then was is
the drinking right because the drink is
to hell with the world right you think I
shouldn't be drinking at night and
coming to work hungover I'll do it
anyway right to hell with the world it's
a way of snubbing his nose at the world
right he's also snubbing his nose at him
right to hell with me right the guy who
now doesn't come across the way he did
before because I'm showing up at work
not in the responsible way I showed up
before I've been a way it's a little
disheveled function is lower to hell
with me right it's a form of
self-denegration like let people think
worse of me right because why because
I'm so mad at myself that I think it's
Justified right and then there's also
the inviting of hey if I if I really
have an addiction problem here I lose my
job it's like fine I deserve that too
right like you know there's an acting
out against the self that if the person
doesn't stop and look at that that can
become true right because that person
didn't really wasn't built to say to
help the world and with me or to not
even understand it what's the hell with
the world means it also means to hell
with me and it's not nothing for the
world over me right but he was able to
understand that because we would look
like wow what shifted in you this is a
person did a lot of sublimation before
who now all of that's going into acting
out so they're not taking negative
energy and doing something good with it
they're taking negative energy and doing
things that are bad with it why because
there's too much there's a lot of
negative energy it's overwhelming
everything else and then it's going down
these Pathways where the the unhealthy
defenses are always beckoning us send
the energy down here it's easier to
avoid than it is to face something and
figure it out right it's easier to just
act out than it is to hold what's inside
of us and then think about why it's
there so the unhealthy defenses are
beckoning us and for him to see hey look
you you have had a healthy defensive
structure like you can be healthy again
you're not broken right but to also see
the way these defenses are going is
bringing real risk to you know to your
to your ability to even be happier you
get further down the shame and loss path
it can be hard sometimes impossible for
the person to get back so it sets the
stage like this is very very important
to what these defenses are how they're
being enacted and for him to be able to
see that like oh this could be healthy
but
it's not now yeah these um
slow uh you know degrading forms of
acting out and self-sabotage and
sabotage of others I I think are the
particularly Dangerous Ones because
because they're slow and the the
sometimes the the change is
imperceptibly slow and then one day
somebody arrives at a place where as you
said you know they of course you can't
get back or that or it requires
um you know going into residential
treatment or things that really you know
big departures yes um it departures in
order to get back into life and
um you know I would never wish for
somebody to choose to act out by driving
off a cliff instead but but there are
other forms of acting out that
immediately wake people up
um but it seems like people don't often
select those they select these more
subtle forms of acting out where they
don't get caught and they or they or no
one's calling them out on on it because
you know you know plenty of people have
five or six drinks at happy hour right
as opposed to 50. right you know so
um so it's it's self slow self sabotage
as opposed to immediate self-destruction
um and again we're talking about alcohol
but we talked about food video games
social media
um uh arguing with spouse I mean all of
these kinds of things that build up over
time to eventually deliver people to a
place of real real problems
um I'm curious for this particular
individual you worked with sounds like
that's not what happened they they
started this process of of self-inquiry
around self-awareness and
um did you see that the
salience that is what they paid
attention to internally and externally
immediately shifted in the defense
mechanism of acting out immediately
dissolved I mean what was the kind of
contour and Time and Time courses there
was less so if we're looking in the
cabinets there's a lot in the defense
mechanisms and action cabinet there's
not as much in the salience cabinet
because this is the major thing on his
mind right above all else like you know
he was having intrusive thoughts about
it and his self-talk was about it but we
kind of already knew that you know just
like we knew it was in the conscious
mind so if you think where's the money
at right it's not as much in that realm
because he's aware of it if he thought
oh I'm not this isn't bothering me very
much and he said well all his internal
dialogue is about it right then like
okay there's a lot there's a lot to
achieve there but just as he brought a
lot that was unconscious into the
conscious mind was aware of it
um it was Salient there's less to do
there right because
the things to understand and change are
not residing
so much there
for people that are
no doubt everyone is seeing about their
own internal processes and um and where
they could ask better questions and and
arrive at better answers to help
themselves along
um perhaps you could uh elaborate a
little bit more on this salience covered
under function of self you know to me
salience is what's most apparent
um and and uh as you talked about
yesterday and again today you know
there's this internal narrative like
what's on my mind often or what kind of
jumps to mind I've started doing this
recently based on our discussions here
um and I've noticed that under different
states of arousal and here I'm talking
specifically about sleepiness versus
alertness type arousal like when I wake
up in the morning or when I'm tired in
the evening you know where my mind is at
where it defaults to
um and what I'm paying attention to
throughout the day
um is that I'm just asking myself to
notice and I've certainly noticed some
some uh some patterns yeah um I for
instance I've noticed that anytime My
overall state is elevated more alertness
or in the middle of exercise my mind
goes to some
um not so pleasant thoughts
um and it's interesting to me it's like
wow this is strongly correlated with
states of internal arousal that are
healthy exercise you know within a
limited frame is is or exercises in
general if done in a healthy way is
healthy
um and when I'm sleepy those thoughts
never come about uh when I wake up in
the morning certain thoughts tend to
LEAP to mind other thoughts no it's a
sort of categorization of different
types of thoughts depending on my
internal state is that the sort of line
of inquiry that you're that you're um
suggesting or describing here yeah it's
I think it's about half the picture
right because half the picture would be
what's going on in your mind when your
mind is sort of at rest right what what
is then starts playing itself right in
your mind right the other side of it is
what comes to the fore when there's a
lot of competition for attention right
so I'm making this up but but the idea
that like if he stubbed his toe really
badly he'd still be thinking about this
right because it's so much power now
again maybe if God forbidity is a badly
broken bone there's a lot of pain like
he's gonna think of that first right but
it takes a lot of other stimulus to to
be more Salient than this right so you
can look at what's coming in your mind
when your mind is sort of free and open
that's very very important and relevant
and then what's winning out when there's
maybe a high arousal State and a lot of
competition for attention
that's very helpful
um again I think that along with this um
self-awareness piece
um the asking of oneself you know what
what
is happening in my mind when I'm in
different states or throughout the day
um and as you're describing now
also including when
um there are other things available to
think about like does that include how
often I'm distracted by a particular
thought like how many times throughout
the day my mind goes from the
conversation I might be into something
else
yes yeah does it hijack your attention
you know there's one way of putting
putting that a lot of people
um mention to me challenges with
intrusive thoughts
um
what can be done about those intrusive
thoughts or is it simply a matter of
paying attention to the fact that
they're there and um and then thinking
about the the origins of those thoughts
right absolutely I mean one example we
could have intrusive thoughts because
there's trauma in your background maybe
very clear trauma that you're not facing
and addressing and then you have
intrusive thoughts that say I'm not safe
okay go look for what's still in the
unconscious mind or when it comes out a
little bit you push back into the
unconscious mind that would be a that's
a very different scenario then like in
this case this man was having intrusive
thoughts about his job situation his
overall situation and it made sense that
he was having those insurance they were
markers of the Acuity of it right of
like you have to do something about this
or like something's very bad is going to
happen so the intrusive thoughts there
and this made sense right like this is
not going well and and your mind is sort
of forcing you to pay attention to this
because time really kind of is of the
essence you're a real risk now so
intrusive thoughts can be anything from
as they often are they can be markers of
something that is traumatic something
that's underneath the surface something
that is really bothering us that we
shoved down that's making guilt shame
distress vulnerability that's that's
very often the case but sometimes
intrusive thoughts are a marker of like
oh right that's the thing to pay
attention to
and once we identify the intrusive
thought I mean how do we eradicate it I
mean how do we uh work with it I mean uh
talking about trauma now you know um of
course it might map back to a childhood
experience
um some internal narrative but
um is there some road map for moving
intrusive thoughts from a place of
intrusive and disturbing to Simply there
and kind of meh
um I mean it'd be wonderful to hit a
delete switch but obviously we don't
work like that well let's take a look if
we could this example right which is a
little bit different if we if we run
through this example of the person in
the job because then we should talk
about trauma driven intrusive thoughts
which is I think in many ways the
biggest topic about intrusive thoughts
but think of this person here if we go
up from salience we look at behaviors
right and behavior actually now is very
very important right this person is
drinking they're still going to that job
they don't want they haven't gone an
interview for the jobs they want right
so we start looking at the behaviors
that are making problems the changes in
behaviors that could make things better
right and then on top of that we arrive
at strivings and I think when I was
talking about structure of self I think
at least one time I misspoke and said
said striving instead of self at the top
of these pyramids self and striving have
a lot of overlap right because if you're
growing a healthy self right out of you
know the sort of top of the structure of
self-pyramid then that self is going to
be aware of strivings and and it's going
to be better able to enact them so you
know his his sense of self was shaken
here but he was aware of the strivings
for a better life right so now let's see
the road map it's interesting right
because the road map is his road map
right if we look in those 10 cupboards
we come up with a road map and roadmap
doesn't have a spending very much time
in like unconscious land right because
it doesn't really need that right if we
look at what makes the difference for
him him what did we do right we really
cultivated the self-awareness the eye
that is making decisions for him we
looked at how his defensive structure
had changed and the things he didn't
want to be there now and the good things
that were there before and how could he
get back some of that how could he Trend
back towards what was working before so
we start to really look at that and then
we go from there really to changing
behaviors like it requires a behavioral
change which is not to walk up to the
precipice of doing this each day but to
actually do it right because it was very
clear all the vectors so to speak inside
of and we're pointing towards doing it
and that that was consistent with this
self being healthier that garden growing
on top of the structure and the striving
then being realized so for him that was
the road map and the the Salient so it
wasn't really part of it because the
intrusiveness the salience bias inside
of it made sense and then like of course
it went away once he made the decision
right because the intrusive thoughts of
like you have to figure this out you
have to figure this out right weren't
there anymore along with the intrusive
thoughts of you'll never figure this out
or like it goes away because he made the
change but he made the change because we
looked at self-awareness and we
strengthened self-awareness we looked at
defense mechanisms how they could be
versus how they are we looked at the
behavioral change which was really
necessary and then also referencing a
character structure that had has
difficulty right coming coming across
the precipice right so we we said okay
that's a baseline characteristic of him
we kind of understand that but how do we
help him change the behaviors anyway
when he does that the self is in a
better happier healthier place the
strivings are realized this person that
stops drinking in the way they were they
start doing the the enjoyment aspects of
their life they start doing them within
reasonable bounds again they're taking
care of themselves a person's smiling
and now think the generative Drive is
much more fulfilled so so what comes on
top of those pillars right is that
person has a sense of humility right
enough humility to say I'm going to walk
away from this job I don't it's okay
that the people in the job will think
I'm crazy how could you leave that and
and like it triggers something in me in
some way but like it's okay right like I
don't I don't have to you know I I'm not
out there for that I'm not out there for
the big thing that everybody is is
guiding I can of the humility to go to
the job that I know makes a difference
and feels good to me right he's
empowered to make change he's moving
away from this the disempowerment to the
alcohol and the avoidance right so
there's empowerment in humility and
absolutely if you talk to that person
on the other side of it like shortly as
it was enacting it right getting just to
the other side of it there was so much
empowerment and so much humility which
were then brought to bear through a
sense of agency that made the changes
right that changed the job that stopped
drinking that dealt with the people who
thought negatively of it right through a
sense of gratitude of it's not awful
that I I'm gonna go make less money a
lot of people said that to him like how
could you do it it was so terrible it's
not terrible right I'm grateful like you
know what I'm going to do I'm going to
go make an amount of money that that's
all that I need right so it was like
that's what helps a person do that thing
and that's actually true right that's
what What mattered to him so and
activated an active a verb sense of
agency and gratitude then leads into the
place where there was that peace
contentment Delight he was delighting in
the job that he chose and his generative
Drive was in accord with it you know
then eventually we stopped at some point
working together like he didn't need me
anymore you could always come back but
wouldn't need me anymore and you look at
how are those last sessions a lot of the
last sessions where him like in an
excited way telling me what he was doing
where are they going then we did this
and like I did this I figured this out
like he was so happy about it and you
can see that man's generative Drive
which naturally naturally is quite high
in him but was being squelched right
that brings him out of balance now the
generative Drive was in quite a good
place and he had enough aggression or
assertion right to to go and do that job
and to do that well and even enough to
counter anybody who would still kind of
rise up and say that wasn't a good idea
he could counter all that he was getting
pleasure from it he didn't need to seek
pleasure by what not even pleasure
because alcohol was pleasurable no
pleasure because harming himself and
saying to hell with you to the world and
to him was pleasurable right you're not
getting pleasure that way he's getting
pleasure in healthier ways taking care
of himself doing the job he loves doing
his leisure activities like the man
comes into balance and then like life is
good and we say yeah okay come back in a
couple months like it comes back in a
couple of months maybe in six months
comes back one more time I don't see him
again that's great he totally doesn't
need me again and I atrophied right from
his life great that's that's the success
state of it he eventually arrived at
being truly wealthy right yeah with all
with all the components of mental health
and
peace contentment Delight that as you
describe his story which is a remarkable
one
um it occurs to me that the narratives
that we hear as children
end up being so powerful yes um and I'm
sure there are people out there that
receive such direct messages from their
mother and or father like you have to do
this you cannot do that
but often we get messages through
observing and overhearing right
um the way that our mother talks about
our father when he's out of the room the
way that our father talks about her
mother when she's out of the room and
some of this could be non-verbal Like a
Rolling of the eyes or a um somebody
saying yes yes agreeing and then they
walk out and they just you know and kind
of blowing them off right I mean kids
are we are all so aware and integrating
all of that all the time and I I do
think those messages get woven into us
at a very deep level absolutely and then
of course there are the conscious
narratives that we build up as we go
through
particular I think elementary and middle
school and high school I mean I can
still remember a negative comment
somebody made about a jacket that I was
wearing in like the third or the fourth
grade I forget everything else that
happened that year I remember that I
remember that yeah and I'm not um you
know I'm not insecure about the clothing
that I pick you know I mean obviously
it's it's a black button-down shirt I've
had similar shirts since the first grade
just kidding um but you know that but we
the fact that that's embedded in my
memory systems is like just it speaks to
the the salience of of negative
of insults basically it was an insult um
and I'm sure I've insulted plenty of
kids and coming up you know as a
teenager and and back and forth and
um and so but these narratives get so
deeply embedded and the idea that one
could pick a different path of vocation
or like or miss the opportunity to be
truly happy at a deep level based on
these narratives I mean on one hand it's
obvious on the other hand you just go
like whoa this is this isn't not good
this is this is a flaw in the in the
design right
um and yet you're giving us a road map
to to understanding and and to um
overcoming it right let's say we take
your examples and we were like they're
great examples and we we look at them
right the the person making fun of the
code in third grade right we're assuming
it hasn't harmed you it doesn't change
your course of your life right what does
it tell us it shows that negative
stimuli are very Salient right I'm sure
you got a lot of compliments in third
grade too right but it's the negative
that stands out which just shows that
there's a salience bias in US towards
the negative and that's probably about
survival and threat sensing like in some
ways it makes sense around human
survival Bible but it doesn't make sense
around human trauma right so then so
you're given the example of what gets
communicated to the child when say
mother says something negative about
father when father's out of the room
father says something negative about
mother when Mother's out of the room
just to give an example right so
children because the the complex
cognitive mechanisms haven't been formed
yet right then the natural way that the
brain functions is in a self-referential
way right so so the child generally
doesn't have the capacity to say like oh
Mom and Dad aren't really getting along
well in in this certain way so when does
not hear mom vents a little bit about
something about him by saying a child
isn't thinking about that right then
what the child will often internalize is
okay there's me and there's mom and dad
and mom says Dad is bad and dad says mom
is bad
and I must be bad too
right because in general if your parents
are bad then then the child takes out on
themselves now again I'm giving a simple
example but I'm very much extrapolating
it I mean imagine if that were very very
aggressive where the mother when this
happens right just tells the child how
awful the father is and the father does
the same you're not gonna someone's not
going to come out the other side of that
being like you know what maybe they're
both awful but I'm not that's not how
that goes right so the lessons the the
traumatic lessons of childhood get
internalized right and they don't even
always have a solution state so so you
think about the man who knew like okay
you have to go get this job and like all
those things he internalized you might
say well I mean he got to a good place
for him right so so For Better or For
Worse at least there was a place to go
right to like to go go work hard go
succeed go check this box you've been
told you're supposed to check but
oftentimes there is no solution state so
how many children I mean it's terrible
that this is such a high percentage of
the work adult practitioners do is is
helping people who has children were
told one way or another that they were
worthless incapable
um bad right that gets that gets put
into the child unfortunately far far I
mean one time on the planet is too
frequent let alone how long how often
this happens
um that example makes really good sense
could we and this is a question could
could we add to that the example whereby
the child overhears
um again examples of what say
men should be like or women should be
like like these things it's not so much
um like you did wrong Andrew or you know
you did wrong Paul like or or telling um
that darl like you screwed up but but
it's more
um again narratives that we overhear or
even a parent
um showing uh Delight or excitement
about a certain phenotype in the world
like oh wow look at that person or look
at them like like isn't she beautiful
right that the young child thinks like
okay well then that's the epitome of
beauty through the lens of the parent or
gosh like this person like Ugh you know
like then that that child internalizes
that this is the epitome of disgust with
another human being and I think children
are so Savvy uh without realizing it
instead of like okay well then I guess
you you move toward that and you and you
aspire to that and you deflect from that
and you can see how these trajectories
can be set very early on I mean these
are the these are the four lane highways
that we were talking about it in episode
one where just routes of neural
processing that could bring us to
choices in life and places in life that
oftentimes you're like I don't want to
go down this path anymore and and so the
the exploration of of early narratives
both direct and indirect you know first
person and third person seem so critical
oh how how does one go about that I mean
clearly with a trained clinician like
you uh you would guide somebody through
the process but if somebody were to try
and do this in some sort of structured
way for themselves and what do those
lines of inquiry look like because we
have vast number of experiences from
childhood but some messages are going to
be more Salient than others sure yeah
the idea that reflective self-scrutiny
you know can help us I think is this a
great idea it's a great concept and and
we we do a lot of different things sort
of inside and we're guided to do a lot
of things inside but this I think should
overshadow many if not most of all those
other things of like what's really going
on inside of me because if you think
about it a lot of people will come
through that and they'll learn right so
the person is told like this is what
beautiful is this is what successful is
this is what good enough looks like
right and and that person may through
all sorts of experiences you know maybe
other people in their lives who are more
balanced be able to arrive on the other
side of that even still sometimes going
through the midst of it depending upon
age and situation you know like okay
like that's what you know my my father
and mother thinks like this is what
beauty is this is what success is but
it's one set of opinions and it's not a
set of opinions that are going to Define
me like sometimes people get to that
place but a lot of times they don't and
they carry that lesson forward and
they're not aware of it right so they
think that they're very unattractive
even though other people are giving them
different signals they think that
they're very dumb even though other
people are giving them different signals
in their own grades and their own
success maybe giving them different
signals right but they're not putting
the two things together and that's going
to generate tension right that might be
why that person doesn't follow up on
potential relationships right they just
don't think they're good enough and the
person's eventually going to reject them
because of what they look like right
they are taking that with them in this
in this example from childhood right or
they're not satisfied with the job that
in other ways is like really great right
they enjoy the work they enjoy
everything but it doesn't pay enough
right why because they have some false
idea inside of what it's supposed to pay
right because it's what the parent said
so so by self-scrutiny of like what are
the Givens I always think it goes back
to the math minor right if you can't
solve the problem go back and look at
the Givens right what are you taking for
granted like oh I know that every time I
see an X at x equals 4 right really
maybe you know maybe you wrote down four
uh somehow because you were thinking of
four at the time and X actually is a
three right it's like just go back and
look at what you're taking for granted
right and a lot of times this is what
we're doing in the therapy process and
that's when the person can realize so
I'm simplifying but for the person to
realize like oh there's a voice in my
head so to speak is a natural voice that
is the voice of this person right who
who may not even be around anymore whose
opinion does it mean is to me what it
did before but that voice is saying
you're unattractive you're not making
enough money you're not good enough
right and you know what I don't believe
that
right I don't they can identify that and
then you can it doesn't happen all at
once but you can get it out of you you
generally you don't get it out of you
unless you realize that it's there what
is the process of getting it out
um because I think that we all have the
capacity to remember certain things and
and to arrive at a place where we can
um understand okay I'm I'm taking for
granted the fact that there's a voice in
my head that says blank actually I have
a brief anecdote to say about this and
this isn't the the quote-unquote I have
a friend thing that I literally have a a
uh a female friend who the other day
called me laughing and crying because um
she was being evicted from her her
apartment and she told her mother about
this over the phone and her mother's
response was well at least you're thin
wow like it like like and and and she
was laughing and crying about it because
it reflected so much of her childhood
right right that like no other
accomplishment of having a job having an
apartment Etc like you know mattered it
was it was it was about one thing it was
about us a certain form of aesthetic
beauty that I'm not even sure she
subscribes to even though she happens to
be thin right so so the fact that her
mother would lift that from
the the conversation there's such a a
deprivation of of so many things in the
in that interaction but but it really
wasn't about that interaction it was you
know she was calling me because it was
really about her entire childhood right
and obviously I'm not equipped to to
solve the problem and it wasn't a
request for money or anything of that
sort it was just it was almost like the
hilarity and the um and the the sadness
of the whole picture right but again
it's
speaks to these narratives that we
internalize and that sometimes show up
in very glaring ways in the real world
it's like to hear that I think was
shocking to her I think she needed to
tell me to like like is this real but
then it was clear that that message had
existed in her head for a long time
anyway
um that could be very pivotal if she
realizes that right and even the power
of the humor of it this is absurd right
that could be very powerful in in
creating change because if there's some
vestiges of that inside of her right
where like she still believes like oh
I'm not good enough because I achieved a
b and c but I don't look like X or
whatever it can very much help because
there's a lot of power behind realizing
that absurdity of like oh my that's
bizarre like so but but wait is any of
that inside of me am I carrying some of
that with me I mean is it incentive for
self-scrutiny and you know through what
you're describing because what's the
ideal amount of that to still be in her
zero
so as as one comes to realize the
messages they've heard or perhaps like
in this case that they're still hearing
is the process of overcoming those
messages and really arriving at the self
it it sounds to me like it's a
two-part process at least two-part
process it's to look in the bin of what
are the Givens what are the what are
what am I taking for granted about the
internal narratives and thinking about
their origins in childhood or elsewhere
but then also cultivating the
self-awareness piece that's under the
function of self like wait what's really
true for me at the level of me that has
that that isn't the and this is really I
think about separating out the voices in
one's head these internalized narratives
from the person that we really truly are
because the idea is that those two
pillars Encompass everything we need to
look at right those those ten cupboards
Encompass everything so it's all that
right the person who's going and looking
at the Givens they're trying to
understand what might be in my
unconscious mind that I'm not aware of
right and oh wow the you know the last
time I got this like big award at work I
had this reflexive thought of like but
you're not thin enough wow whoa right
like there could be a process like
that's going on inside of me I don't
want that going on inside of me right so
the processary what is unconscious in us
that may be causing us harm which is
often where that's where the trauma goes
right it's where the childhood trauma
seats itself which brings us back around
to the intrusive thoughts right
intrusive negative thoughts negative
self-dialogue usually does not mean what
it meant to the man who need to change
jobs right because there they were there
for a good reason right then he needed
to make change more often there the the
the vestiges The Hangover the lingering
Badness of some prior trauma so
oftentimes when you think we talked a
little bit yesterday about the person
who was driving in the car and just
telling themselves over and over that
they were that they're a loser right and
then they can't achieve the things that
they achieved when they stopped doing
that I'm simplifying a little but that's
the basics of it right because the the
intrusive thoughts the self-narrative
all the negative activity in US is often
coming from places that are in the
unconscious mind right not always but
this idea that I don't think I'm good
enough I'm saying to myself over and
over again like well let's go back and
look at why because the answer to that
again lies in a different place it's
just a different road map right the man
who needed to change jobs had a road map
that like spent a little bit of time in
the eye self-awareness and then it kind
of then it went through
self-defense mechanisms In Action Land
and it spent a lot of time with behavior
and then it got up to the stripings
that's his that's his road map whereas
for someone who's laboring under the
intrusive thoughts the negative
self-talk the automaticity the Givens of
childhood trauma that needs to go to a
different place where now we're spending
time with the in the unconscious mind
thinking about what's there figuring out
what's there bringing things to
Consciousness right that person say
realizing maybe you know your friend you
had this realization of like oh my
goodness we say wow did that bring
something to the conscious mind in her
if so great let's look at that and let's
look a lot at it and let's look are
there other things there too right are
there other Givens right let's bring
them the conscious to Consciousness so
that we can talk about them we can
identify them and then look at how does
that how does that relate to defense
mechanisms and character structure and
like now what are we doing a process of
of interested inquiry like this is
really interesting I mean it should be
interesting to the person doing it it's
them right and it should be interesting
to the person doing it with them right
because if you're a therapist it is not
interesting to you you need another job
right so or you're talking to a friend
like if it's a friend is going to be
interested so if there's an interested
honest open inquiry with the idea of
holic we're going to let's learn things
so that we can make change for the
better and even though as we talked
about yesterday the intrusive thoughts
and the self-dialogue that's going on
over and over and over again it doesn't
go away easily but that doesn't mean it
it doesn't atrophy over time and go away
or that the person can have that
reflexive thought like oh there's a
thought again that I'm a loser or that I
should cut myself or I should drink or
whatever it isn't like I know that
thought appears in me automatically at
times because it was in my head for so
long but it does not telling me anything
right it's just an automatic thought
it's something I should drink don't tell
me anything right other than the fact
that like oh that's what happens in
human beings like that's how the
self-understanding brings change in us
and gets us over the barriers of why
I've been trying this for you know what
modern mental health would often ever
think I I took the selection I did the
10 sessions of CBT like like you know
I'm a failure nothing will ever get
better you know a different framing that
says hey like this can get better over
time and my understanding and my efforts
and my thought redirection my behavioral
changes all makes it better and then
those things I don't want in my head
they're going away
it's taking time but they're going away
I'm relieved to hear you say that one
can have intrusive thoughts and that one
approach to dealing with those is to
acknowledge them and look at them and
not try and push them back deeper uh you
know not trying to eradicate them
um
I'm familiar with having intrusive
thoughts not all the time but it varies
periods throughout my life and
um the idea that one can just like
extinguish them is is a great idea but
it's simply not the way it's worked at
least not for me but I have found that
if I you know just say okay this is
spontaneously coming up through the
neural circuits of my subconscious and
and they're intrusive and I don't like
them but
I eventually arrive at exactly the place
that you describe which is that it's
like there's nothing actionable here
like it's just they they go from being
um intrusive and and troubling to
intrusive and just kind of mildly
irritating to intrusive and like okay
you know I I just um uh you know and yes
I go through some redirect like trying
to redirect my attention from time to
time when they're happening but I
eventually just get to a place where
it's like okay it's just a boring story
or or boring imagery there's nothing
there like there's nothing there and
then they eventually break up like like
clouds and then that process can take a
while but right because you took the
energy out of them right you made them
go away which happened over time and
then the energy that was so powerful
becomes less and less and listen what
happens they dissipate they atrophy
right that's how they go away because
there's no more power there's no more
power in them and and that really is the
way that we make change and I think you
know your emphasis upon
the fact that it takes time the fact
that it takes effort the fact that it
only goes away slowly over 20 years of
of at times being a therapist right what
I've seen be the most daunting the thing
that makes people just give up and go
away and go back to the things that are
bad give up on themselves are that it
takes time and you know if you think
it's supposed to take two weeks and the
world around you is kind of leading you
to think that and then you go for help
and the help kind of leads you to think
that whether it's two weeks or it's ten
weeks if it's going to take two years
you're going to go away
disheartened right you're maybe more
angry at yourself or maybe demoralized
so we we have to look at the truth of
all of this say parallel to your story
in my own life for for years and years
and years I carried a negative voice
inside there's always waiting for me to
do something wrong so if I say something
that's a little bit off or not exactly
what I want to say now it would say like
that wasn't good like it says something
negative inside to me or it's waiting
for me to drop something and say that
I'm stupid and clumsy right with me all
the time but over time through
self-reflection through therapy like
through a lot of hard work but a desire
for things to be better and a desire to
understand it right like it's not there
anymore I mean every now and then it'll
raise its head right I'll do something
really I dropped a cup of coffee I
haven't done it in 10 years and it made
a mess and now people are coming to
clean it up and man The Voice came back
right but I could recognize it right
like I really feel bad about this and
now it gives that voice a chance to come
out but it doesn't come out much anymore
whereas what I lived with it for years
doesn't come out much anymore and when
it came out not that long ago like I
could recognize like I'm not happy I did
this and let me help clean it up but it
doesn't mean I'm an idiot right so so
the voice in my head can just go away as
it's as I've been helping it to do for a
bunch of years now yeah I think also
important for people to understand is
that it takes time but that we can all
potentially engage in right actions you
know moving towards strivings and
hopefulness as we cope with those and
try and diminish those internal
narratives those intrusive thoughts it's
not as if during the entire process you
you know you can't function I mean I
think that the uh it's uh cognitively
and sometimes even physically demanding
to do but we can still engage in healthy
ways in in the world and we can
um still try and uh avoid acting out and
and avoid um forms of denial and as I
say this I'm realizing that you know
that the wish for or the impulse to
really just suppress intrusive thought
born of trauma or whatever else is is
really futile like that's not gonna work
does it it's not going to work we have
to embrace these narratives and and not
expect them to disappear in a finger
snap but but embrace them and like see
them and look at them and and and be
unafraid to look at them and
um discount where they are absolutely
not true right um I would say unafraid
to understand right because we must
understand means we must look at what's
going on inside of us when I didn't like
that voice but was afraid of it like
what is going on inside me what does
this say about me and I'm and I'm
directing away from it well that's why
it was with me for like
several decades right but when I start
to go look at it I can find an answer to
it and again it you have to look at
what's going on in that person because
one might presume and maybe people are
saying are presuming this or maybe not
but but but a reasonable presumption
that might just reflexively happen in a
person would be to think that oh when I
was younger the messaging I was getting
was that you're not good enough right
you're not good enough right that's why
I carry with me that you're not good
enough right but it's not that
sometimes it's the opposite that I was
rewarded a lot when I was younger for
doing things in a way everyone thought
was great right like getting great
grades and being well behaved and doing
all sorts of things that brought a lot
of positive reinforcement to me but I
never handled well things that fell even
a little bit short of that and then it
would evoke a lot of Shame so so the
oppression inside is not coming from
denigration is coming from something
different right which is which is also
why this is not a search to blame
someone right because sometimes the the
people who are giving the message like
they're doing the best they can I mean
someone who's saying to a child you're a
loser like that's not okay right no
matter what that's not okay but but
that's often not how it happens like you
know the parent like he says
communicating they don't realize that
that every time they're admiring a
certain level of wealth or a certain
kind of beauty they're giving that
message that the child that that doesn't
meet that or is it ends up not meaning
that isn't good enough like but they
don't know that or you know I had like
my parents tried to nurture me and they
did a good job of it in many ways and
teachers did a good job but so they
they're realizing hey this person is
going to end up you know a bunch of
years from now not thinking anything's
you know good enough and I mean they
don't know that so it's not a search for
blame and I think that's very very
important very important because often
people don't want to look inside because
they think either I'm gonna find
something dramatically wrong with me and
the answer I would give is there's
almost surely not something dramatically
wrong with you if you're having that
thought and if somehow there is you're
better off looking at it now than later
right and so that's part of it the other
part is that that people become worried
that they're going to ruin something you
know I'm gonna I like my parents and if
I go look at this I'm gonna I'm gonna
I'm gonna hate them like people say say
things or think things like that and the
idea that we may get down to something
that really involves someone being
responsible for something bad now that's
if that's the truth the person already
knows that inside the vast majority of
times they know that they're just not
facing that but most of the time also
it's not that it's just like okay that's
how life evolved and what's the
predisposition like you know I was smart
enough to get good grades and I have a
low threshold for shame and people
reinforce me and and like oh like I can
kind of understand that so then I can
get control over it it's not a search
for anger frustration blame of self or
others yeah and oftentimes I I hear that
people are afraid rate of dealing with
these deeper issues or addressing these
deeper issues for fear that they'll lose
say their their drive right the thing
that makes them successful in the first
place and that allows them perhaps even
to afford therapy or afford the time to
think about these sorts of questions so
it seems to me that
the drives that you referred to earlier
the generative Drive the aggressive
drive and the pleasure Drive
are such critical nodes or areas to look
for all of us in terms of
figuring out whether or not we're doing
well or less well according to some
features that are pretty much Universal
in people essentially what I'm saying is
um at least by my understanding
we all have drives to some extent or
another
and to the extent that our aggressive
Drive is very high and pleasure Drive is
very high and whether or not it's
pointed in the right direction it can be
generative if it's not perhaps it can
undermine our generative drive I'm very
curious to know
how you've observed the different ranges
of these drives in people and how that
predicts whether or not people will do
more or less well in different areas of
life essentially how the different
drives play out
I think the first thing to say is where
the drives are at so to speak in in any
of us is a combination of Nature and
nurture so the the nature part tells us
the the range sort of that the drive is
going to be but because nurture means so
much to humans as we understand from
epigenetics from from the advance of
science we see more and more and more
how much nurture matters so the range
that's denoted by nature is probably
pretty broad I mean we see the
manifestation of that and then the
nurture lets us then move that drive now
sometimes nurture that's not gone in the
right place can move the drive in the
wrong direction right but as as adults
as people who can take care of ourselves
who can learn about ourselves we can
change where the drives are seated it's
not an easy thing to do because it
requires a lot of changes of self with
self-knowledge and hard work and but we
can do it right we can change the the
sort of array of how those drives are
manifesting themselves within us and we
see that I mean that's part of the
hopefulness of mental health treatment
right that we see not just surface
changes but we can see changes on a
deeper level so I think it's important
that these things are not fixed although
there are some natural elements you know
someone who may have a natural sort of
low aggression or low self-assertion
okay it's going to be in the lower range
but it doesn't mean that it's locked in
at any one particular point and that the
place that we want to be what is the
place that's consistent with the things
that we want the the agency and
gratitude as verbs and the uh the sense
of well-being and all of that so the the
idea is the state of health has the
generative drive as as prominent right
that's it's the dominant drive and then
aggression and pleasure which are still
active in us but they're subserving the
generative drive and that's the state
that we wish to be in so when we're
assessing okay why why is there
something that doesn't feel okay or
something that's not going okay right
then one way way to start is to look at
okay what's going on in the person what
may be off in the drives that gives us a
very strong idea of okay what's going on
a way of understanding what's going on
as we then go and look in the ten
cupboards to figure out the specifics
okay what is actually going on here that
we can then change but the framing of
what's going on can come through the
lens of looking at the drives and how
they're manifest in us what does it look
like when the aggressive Drive is very
high
and the pleasure Drive is also very high
so if these drives are running too high
where we end up at is in a place of Envy
right and and envy I I'm always sort of
on the soapbox about Envy because I
think Envy is just so wildly destructive
and if the aggressive Drive is very high
so the person say in in one way of uh
one way this can manifest itself just
wants more and more and more right
they're not getting satisfaction from
anything but they want more that may be
because of a strong vulnerability inside
of them so something that might map to
to narcissism for example there's a
there could be a strong aggressive drive
to get more and that leads to something
that's very unhealthy so the idea that I
want more I need more I don't have
enough I can't get enough then Fosters
Envy right which is the the not the
desire to like be better or to have more
but it's just the desire to feel better
about the self whether that involves
raising the self up or bringing someone
else down that's why Envy is destructive
so very high levels of aggression that
are not tempered for example by a
generative drive that would also be high
then create a circumstance of envy and
the Envy is destructive and the same
happens if the pleasure Drive is very
very strong so so if one continues to
want more pleasure so I can't find any
satisfaction I don't feel good about
myself I feel bereft inside right and
and I see that oh pleasure can make me
feel better but just for a little bit
right then it fades away and I want more
of it and I want more of it that also
can lead to the place of Envy like
that's the outcome so if the aggressive
Drive is running very high or the
pleasure Drive is running very high or
if both are running very high but it
only takes one in order to end up in a
place of Envy so if the generative drive
is not high enough to overcome how high
the aggressive Drive is which would mean
then the aggressive driver sublimated
towards good productive things so take
the energy and put it towards something
that is goodness but if the aggressive
Drive is was way out their head of the
generative drive that ends up in a place
of Envy as does the pleasure drive if I
want more and more and more but I never
get satisfaction from from anything it
never brings me any sense of goodness
that where it ends is is in a place of
of vulnerability and resentment right
because Envy involves wanting more right
and an Envy if we look at what's really
going on Envy under the surface involves
wanting everything right if a person is
at the outer limits of Envy right which
is why Envy is so destructive because if
I can't get enough pleasure and there's
so much aggression in me then I'm not
going to make myself feel better but
what I can do is make other people feel
worse I want to ask you more about Envy
but first I want to ask
is one way to characterize the
generative drive and to distinguish it
from the other drives is to say that
generative drives are pro-social meaning
they tend to bring about benevolent
interactions between people in the sense
that so Pro social as constructive right
as as in a sense building goodness then
yes because it's the drive in us that
makes us want to love and nurture things
right that makes us want to learn and
and sometimes learn to make better in
the world or learn for learning's sake
that there that the drive is a drive of
goodness so if the drive is then gonna
gonna enact itself in the world around
us it's going to be pro-social because
we exist as social units right I mean if
we decide oh I want to be an island off
somewhere like that's not healthy right
we exist in Social units from small like
a nuclear family right to a neighborhood
right all the way up to Nations and to
the to the planet so if we if we
perceive the truth of that that hey
there's an interdependence between me
and others and and I see that then the
drive will leave to choices and
behaviors that are socially constructive
earlier you talked about aggression and
you were clear to make sure that we all
understood that aggression does not
necessarily mean violent aggression
right um that there are different forms
of aggression I'm curious if you could
give us some examples of how you've
observed
um people with high levels of aggression
and high levels of pleasure drive as
well both male and female and you know
here without
um defaulting to stereotypes I think a
lot of people just
despite the fact that you've clarified
what aggression is and isn't in this in
the context of this conversation we hear
the word aggression and we think uh
verbal attack physical attack however
the way you're describing aggression and
the aggressive drive I have a feeling
that you're referring to other
expressions of aggression as well so if
the aggressive Drive is running too high
and that could have factors of nature
factors of nurture right factors of the
situation the person is in factors of
their whole life but it ends up at the
moment in a place that is too high then
what that person is doing in one way or
another is to try and exert an unhealthy
level of control and that can be done in
so many different ways it can be done in
that overt way of just intimidating
people right of of using harsh language
for its people it can be done by
manipulating people it can be done
through passive aggression there are all
sorts of ways that the person can try
and exert unhealthy control but that's
where we end up if there's too much
expression of the aggressive Drive in US
that makes sense and it reminds me of an
example from my own life where
um well first off I should say I've had
almost exclusively positive
collaborations among my colleagues at
Stanford and elsewhere like every one of
those collaborations has ended in a
paper that we were all happy with but
more importantly the relationships grew
and uh we're not diminished right
um but I had one collaboration with
someone not to be named where
um it was going very well but I had the
need to reschedule an appointment so I
sent a head a note about the fact that
my car needed dealing with I had some
other things I explained why I need to
reschedule the appointment
um and didn't receive a reply which was
a little unusual but then eventually
received a reply that said
um
well it's clear that you don't want to
pursue this collaboration which is like
the furthest thing from the truth right
and Sox
um and so I expressed that and then the
collaboration was reinstated but it it
brought to mind some concern for me
um because it was sort of an extreme
reaction to you know something that
happens in academics
um or anyone we get busy where things
come up it was important to tend to uh
the car that is
and then at some point later
um they were late to a number of
meetings okay no big deal we're
academics we tend to run late that's
typical of many academics but then I was
late once to a meeting and they
essentially left and wrote an email that
said something of the sort like I've got
my own great ideas so I'm no longer
interested in pursuing the collaboration
and I and I was like pretty shocked
right because
um there was nothing really outside the
ordinary in terms of busyness and
prefaceorial schedules and there were
other people involved post-docs and
things like that and there was a great
project to be you know to be worked out
so I remember being disappointed but
also really kind of surprised but then
when I mapped it back to the earlier
example of the right cards and I thought
well like there's a real
um sort of lack of ability this person
to handle disappointment and yet they're
exerting or demonstrating rather some of
the same behavior of
occasionally running tardy and these
kinds of things
um and I remember feeling like it was
pretty aggressive like it's a pretty
aggressive reaction to something that
you know could have been handled with a
conversation now I must say I'm very
grateful that the collaboration didn't
proceed and it went elsewhere and it
worked out great and they're doing great
and we're doing great and so no hard
feelings but
um it stands out to me as a as a pretty
Salient example of aggression but not
played out at the level of yelling or
anything there's a passivity in there
but then there's also kind of a uh kind
of entitlement and here of course I'm
only looking at the other person's
behavior and I should acknowledge I
realize canceling not good being late
not good but listen I'm a human being
and I you canceled once you were late
once this isn't yeah this isn't habitual
this is human stuff right right and a
lot of um a lot of good work had gone
into the project right and there was a
cost where a you know most most
importantly the postdocs offered because
they weren't involved in these
interactions at all and and yet that the
project halted at that point
um so to me that seems like an example
of
um somebody who has a well strong
aggressive drive and that's clear from
the they're incredibly successful in in
the academic domain
um and when disappointed you know lashes
back or is passive one or one or the
other is that is is that what we're
getting at here right um not
surprisingly perhaps the the person
rarely publishes with other people right
probably that doesn't make a very good
collaborative partner right and it
totally makes sense I mean think about
what you're describing here right which
is some vulnerability in the person
there's some way in which the person
doesn't feel good enough no matter what
this person is achieved so then there's
a sense of of the need and the right to
Over Control so when you agree to work
together you know you didn't agree that
I'll never have to cancel anything right
but but the thought was different the
framing is different on the on the other
end that now we've we've we're going to
work together right so I'm exerting
significant control over you right and
again you're not aware of it right and
maybe that he's not aware of it in this
case it was a she okay okay so I was
thinking of someone different but she
has to have some deficit of self that
that results then in the reflexive need
to over control and and think about the
first response is a non-response right
which is that's aggression but it's just
it's just passive aggression right the
thought would be well you're worried
something doesn't feel good in you
because I didn't respond which was true
right you're expecting a response maybe
you don't know did you get the email you
know what's happening is she mad so it's
sort of effective it creates some
consternation and some dissonance in you
right then on top of that the person is
willing to potentially at that point
sacrifice the relationship right so you
think about aggression now is not good
right this excess aggression is not good
for you it also is clearly eclipsing the
generative drive right because it's not
good for this person and their research
it's not good for this person and the
postdocs in their lab right but but the
person is willing to accept that in the
service of gratifying the excess in
aggression now so then you said
something that then sort of made it okay
right for the short term okay then the
person feels gratified like whether you
apologize or not they took it as you
know you've to some degree bowed down
before me now like it'll be okay for at
least for the short term right but then
the next thing that happens actually
does end
the collaboration right so that's not
good right and you see even from a
self-serving perspective that person was
collaborating with you for a reason
right she saw a benefit to the science
that she's very very interested in
through the collaboration with you but
then let that all go right in the
service of what in in the service of of
the ego right of you know my I don't
feel good enough about myself right the
response to that then is is a response
of envy that I don't like that you have
the freedom to behave differently than I
want you to right I don't like any of it
I don't like that I don't control you as
much as I would like to and ultimately
it's that envy that becomes destructive
so it's a setback for that person it's
destructive of the science that person
was doing it's destructive of the
science that you were doing so Envy is
destructive and here the the the high
level of aggression the aggressive
drives at a very high place it's
exceeding the generative Drive the
pleasure Drive isn't high enough either
because there's not enough pleasure
coming from the great science that's
being done right so then the person is
approaching the world through the lens
of Envy right they don't feel good
enough they want to exert that
aggression through over control and what
they end up doing is destructive right
and it's very clearly destroyed it's a
great example because it's destructive
of the science which is ostensibly the
reason that you're there right that's
the reason you were there but someone
who needs to exert Over Control is there
not just for that reason and then the
other reasons can Trump the generative
reason
that they're there and that's how Envy
when when it is the product of
aggression or pleasure seeking being too
high always unfailingly creates
destruction and how different is that
from agency and gratitude as active
verbs right there's there's a sense of
agency but the agency isn't being
exactly enacted because if the agency is
being enacted in the service of science
or career or whatever it may be that's
not that's not going so well right and
and the Gratitude part isn't active like
my goodness I'm here like I have this
great career I'm discovering things I
get to spend my life in science I get to
collaborate with you like there's so
many things to feel good about I have
postdocs in my lab right I get to
nurture them because I know more and I
can guide that's not leading right Envy
is not those things which is why people
who are doing that at least in this
realm of Life although this often no
this bleeds into other Realms of Life
what you the vast majority of times you
see is someone who does not have
happiness right in the way that we're
the happiness with the quotes right that
happiness is you know the sense of peace
right the sense of of uh well-being
right this this being able to Delight in
things contentment right the person
doesn't have that right and here it's
interesting right this person gets to
the highest levels of Academia and
they're very successful and they have a
lab of their own and they're
collaborating you think that's all great
right but not inside of them it's not
bringing them those things it's
evidenced by how this person is behaving
and I would bet almost 100 if you say
what's that person like in other aspects
of Life at least in the professional
World probably in others too no one's
going to describe a happy person
so much of what you just said captures
this individual
um
extremely well and um it also reminds me
that so much of the way that you're
describing this aggressive Drive
can also be observed perhaps in the way
that people show up to social
interactions not necessarily big
interactions maybe even just
interactions between two people what I'm
I'm thinking of here is the the person
male or female who shows up and and just
kind of takes over like like talks the
whole time and tells stories I went to a
meal at the when I graduated University
and someone showed up for the first time
um at this meal meaning we had never met
them before and just like sat down and
just started telling stories for like an
hour and it was interesting portions of
it were captivating and then at some
point I realized like this is this is
either total pathology like this person
is is crazy but they weren't crazy or
um they have no recognition that they're
absorbing all the oxygen in the room as
it's sometimes described
um but it seemed like they had this need
to just control the whole environment by
way of speech just like you know fire
hose stories
um and I've seen this
definitely in the academic realm I've
seen this in the non-academic realm in
Social settings and and what's
interesting is perhaps why this person
does this or these people do this but
what's also interesting is how people
react to it you know that on the one
hand it I think most people find that
kind of obnoxious but there also seem to
be people who see this as like oh that
person
has a lot of agency like that they're a
leader like they they actually grab a
lot of the attention that they're
seeking and we tend to view those people
as kind of empowered I don't actually
think that they're necessarily empowered
but but perhaps it stems from the
feeling that the rest of us I like to
think have which is some sense of social
etiquette where there's some give and
take you know you walk into a room you
kind of assess you know what's the
context here there's some listening as
well as some speaking uh and so on and
and so when someone shows up and kind of
violates all those rules on the one hand
it can be obnoxious and overtake
everything but is it so before you know
there's also this the sense of like oh
like
that must be nice to just be able to
like be as one one feels
um and so I think um I'm describing this
not because I think people should mimic
this type of behavior either way you
know be really Meek and not say anything
that's on their mind or just overtake
but because I feel like it might be an
exploration of this aggressive Drive
um and if someone's doing that are they
trying to like mask something else
um and why do people react to uh these
seemingly powerful people in this way
these things happen in the world around
us right they're independent of the
spectrum of gender the spectrum of
intelligence achievement right they're
human problems so a person you're
describing whether that person has
character structure problems that that
are present with them across time or
whether they're in a certain place you
know whether it's in Life or today like
we don't know for sure what the
underpinnings but but what you're
describing is it's a presentation of
narcissism
right and her narcissism is rooted not
in confidence not in arrogance right
it's rooted in vulnerability it's rooted
in I don't feel good enough and
narcissism then then engages with the
world through the lens of Envy so no one
else gets to have any time no one else
gets to say anything funny no one else
maybe gets to say anything at all right
there's a there's a dominance of the
room right there's a dominance of the
room that comes through an inability to
tolerate the back and forth of human
interactions right human engagement
right so then that person becomes very
dominant and why is that because when
they tell a story and they get a laugh
or even if it's not that funny and it's
a 15 story but somebody Smiles a little
bit or nobody Smiles they can perceive
inside that like I just did that I said
that and maybe somebody responded
positively I feel good about that for a
split second now that's gone and they
then you know then the next thing comes
and the next thing comes because people
who are coming at the world through the
lens of narcissism whether it's just in
that particular event right or it's
across life right are never satisfied
and nothing ever brings enough goodness
nothing ever brings enough feeling of
pleasure so the person then wants more
and that's how the person dominates the
room now that can be very seductive
right narcissistic people not always but
are often very seductive because of that
appearance of Mastery right of control
so that person did have we could look at
it in the short term and say that person
had Mastery over the room right no one
said anything for an hour but them right
so they had Mastery over the room they
had control over the room but what
they're doing is exerting over control
right in the short it's like you know
Pennywise and pound foolish right they
borrow a dollar today to pay back 100
tomorrow right because they got to
control that room but a lot of people
people not everyone right some people
are seduced by it right but a lot of
people will take away from that
something that's not a good feeling
something that wasn't Mutual that
doesn't make a person wants to
collaborate with that person even be in
the same space as that person right so
it's it's counterproductive right
because the people who might come under
the spell so to speak right they're the
people who are brought under the spell
right they're less observant Dynamic you
know intuitive introspective they're
they're not the people that you want in
a sense on your side right the people
that would be most valuable to
collaborate with even his thought
Partners have conversations with but
those people are going to be put off
because even if they don't know exactly
what's wrong they know like that didn't
feel good and they map do I want that
feeling more in my life no right so
that's the counterproductive aspects
that's why narcissism is destructive
because you may say well there's nothing
destructive in that you know in that
interaction but again you have to be
standing so up close to it that you
don't see the bigger picture because
when you stand back from that that's not
a person who's by and large you know you
see that's not a person who's
interconnected in the world around them
has a group of good supportive friends
has a bunch of colleagues where they can
sort of exchange information and and you
know because all that social Dynamic has
to happen in the rest of life so you're
seeing a situation that is that is
counterproductive that is destructive
and you always see that when people are
enacting narcissism whether it's okay
but a bunch of bad things have happened
and for whatever reason like I'm in an
unhealthy place and I'm enacting it
right now or if I'm enacting it every
day of my life because it's in my
character structure and I have it
recognized and and changed it it's
always destructive the narcissists that
I've known and observed almost always
seem to have a partner who
um clearly supports their narcissism or
at least doesn't speak up very much
against it at least not publicly and not
much else except a professional role in
fact there's one scientist who I did not
work with who comes to mind and the joke
about him was always that um this person
would talk about themselves endlessly
for the first half hour that you run
into them and say okay well enough about
me why don't you tell me about me
um this person moved to a different
country with their partner comes back
every once in a while has essentially
done nothing over the last
um decade or so kind of left the field
and um it's kind of the secretly the
laughing stock of the field there was a
one other anecdote about this person I'm
just I'm not picking on them I'm just
trying to explore the these dimensions
of aggression and and low pleasure uh
Drive
um and envy
um
at lab meetings it was it was well known
that they would host a basketball game
um but it was well known that you
um did not want to score like you know
on this person right um because you
would be asked to leave the lab and
indeed several people were asked to
leave the laboratory for having me
embarrassed the the lab head at one of
these lab events by participating in
exactly the event that was described in
the way it was described and doing
something competent right so so the the
game was essentially a way of for the
person to build themselves up
and they were a mediocre at best
basketball player so like here's this
game where everyone's expected to
pretend right and I have to imagine
pretend that the person is actually
better at what they do than they are and
and in some ways this it feels like a
like a replicas of how narcissism shows
up in so many other areas of life like
you said you know these people are
rarely surrounded by people who
um are
actually very bright self you know um uh
self-effacing Etc you know who
um they tend to gather people that just
support them or no one at all because
because no reasonably healthy person
would would choose to be around that
right because that that game is a
metaphor for all of life for that person
it's sending that message like see this
message and extrapolate it out to
everything else right and what is so
what's the metaphor what's it
communicating he's communicating that
you don't
do anything better than I do
right you don't rise above me
interestingly right you don't arise
above me in any way you don't get to
know things I don't know you don't get
to do anything better than than I than I
do right or I will be destructive
towards you
right it's it's fascinating because it's
not about the game right the the game is
a way of of of
communicating that message right
interesting the person's not even that
good at the game like why not choose
something you're really good at right
because then the message is not
communicated as clearly right and a lot
of this is coming is unconscious let's
choose something I'm kind of fair to
middling at right and then make it very
clear that no one gets to be better or I
do something disruptive to them I mean
that's exactly what that is and and
imagine like someone is thrown out of
the lab right I mean like this is in
many ways like like the biggest thing in
their life or one of the biggest things
that's anti-generative I mean the the
cost of that in the larger world is one
less potentially fantastic scientist
right and that's the broader that's
always the broader picture because the
narcissist is standing very very close
to the tapestry right and and so so the
interaction there is
um you have squared a basket when I have
not right so you don't understand the
message that you're not supposed to
exceed me and now I will get rid of you
because you're dangerous to have around
right because you don't get the message
and and you may exceed me in other ways
and also I'm going to feel better
because I have the power to be punitive
right even though it's wantonly punitive
right and completely unjustified but I
have the power to do that and it'll make
me feel good than to push you away and I
know that's not going to be good for you
and I'll feel good about that right but
that doesn't last of course that's why
the person continues to do it and it
also doesn't understand at all that like
that's not good for science right or
most importantly that's not good for me
right as a graduate student in that lab
because you didn't say fire the
graduates to make the graduate student
leave if the person wasn't good no it's
make the graduate student leave no
matter what so the person is doing
things that are injurious to the society
around us obviously to the specific
person they're targeting and also to
themselves and that's where if you
follow if you follow envy and you see
high levels of it in situations that are
unbounded it's like this situation is
unbounded in the sense that the person
can do that there's no higher authority
right well Labs um not this is changing
um and by the way I should back up a
second and say that I do believe and
it's been my experience that most
scientists and lab heads are not
narcissists are quite kind or benevolent
I mean they'd be a little quirky where
scientists after all but um but not
narcissists um at the same time it is
true that for a long time less so now
Laboratories were sort of like little
fiefdoms there was very little oversight
from the universities and so the lab you
joined became your entire world and
Landscape right and there was some
exploitation by narcissistic lab heads
for sure
um yeah as you said it was unbounded
right like there was no oversight
whereas this would be much harder to
recreate today if someone wanted to and
I think that's why by almost everyone
listening to this will it will resonate
with them they'll find some familiarity
because you see this you can see this in
situations where there's a bounded group
of people right this is just a certain
group of people in a certain situation
and that's who they are but the
authority of the person leading the
group is unbounded so there's a
situation where if that person has
narcissistic Tendencies aggressive Drive
is too high pleasure Drive is high but
not being met if all of those things are
happening that's when you see this come
to light which is why the destruction
varies based upon the destruction that's
permissible within the framework right
so here that this person wasn't going to
like fire everyone in their lab right so
in a sense they could only damage their
Labs so much although maybe if you
damage your lab so much you don't get
funding you inadvertently sync yourself
right so so even there that person could
bring about their own destruction but
when you see the other end where it's
truly unbounded like in the sense of War
right as someone who has who can control
a machine of War who who then has
everything right like what do they need
right well they need something they
don't have and never will get so so now
they start enacting more and more is
destructive right and you think oh that
person wants something I mean how many
times does someone start a war right
that's that's clearly an unjustified War
right it's a war because they they want
something then they get something and
they're satisfied
that's not how it goes right then they
get something and they're not satisfied
and they want more so in in discussions
at times about narcissism and envy and
and how that can play out on the the
world stage so sometimes you know huge
events in human history will come up and
people for example will bring up Adolf
Hitler and and the idea that Hitler
wanted things wanted things
no the the the Unbound narcissism the
Unbound Envy wanted destruction right
this is a person who if things have
continued to go as this person intended
right there would have been no one left
on Earth but him because the process is
nothing but destructive which is why
after the fact that there's incalculable
human Carnage right and he himself was
among the incalculable human Carnage
because that's the end point of
narcissism that's the of narcissism on a
broad stage right that's the end point
of Envy at its highest magnitude and we
see that as examples whether we see on
the smaller stage of the lab right right
ahead that you're describing or on the
larger stage of of unbounded War we end
up with destruction like 100 time that's
the final common pathway for all of that
are there some consistent themes of
childhood that lead somebody to become a
narcissist and in addition to that I'm
curious whether or not narcissists ever
have
Insight whether or not if offered the
opportunity to explore the ten cupboards
under the structure of self and function
of self whether or not they eventually
see inside those cupboards and go oh my
goodness I've got this self that's
clearly over inflated and I've got these
defense mechanisms and I'm so envious in
the end and modify their behavior or
whether or not the narcissists are
immune from uh constructive
self-reflection to answer the the first
part is is the vast majority of
narcissism it may be all of it we don't
know for sure is is rooted in the
childhood trauma of not feeling good
enough right which is not an excuse
right for people doing doing awful
things it's not what we're saying we're
trying to have an explanatory mechanism
right which which goes back to formative
life experiences and not feeling good
enough whether it was because that
person was directly denigrated or that
person wasn't denigrated but could never
work hard enough never could could be
enough enough to to to get um approval
right again it's not 100 in human beings
are complicated but if you go and look
you see that that there was never a
state of like oh I feel good enough
about myself right and if there's never
a state of I feel good enough about
myself because someone has told me that
and give me the pat on the head or
giving me the positive comment you can
see how in a certain sort of natural lay
of the land genetically and in in
concert with with other experiences that
person can get to adulthood with with a
lot of aggression in them and never
having experienced I'm good enough it's
still running along inside of them and
then they're enacting that aggression in
the world around them that's most
commonly what we see and because there's
such deep
vulnerability and such deep insecurity
than people say people who suffer from
full-blown narcissism narcissistic
personality disorder so an action of
Envy on the on the highest levels that
is
they're so defended they're so strongly
defended in an unhealthy manner from
seeing their own vulnerability that it
is extremely difficult to get that
person to come around and say okay let's
look in those 10
cupboards within the field people often
talk about treating narcissistic people
they talk about it in a nihilistic way
and and some you see very experienced
people say oh that's impossible all
right that never gets better now I'm not
a believer in therapeutic nihilism I I
think that yes it is it is the norm that
that person just can't get it together
to go look at that thing they're so
defended against it they're so afraid of
it right they won't look anywhere near
it so they're looking in the other
direction and they're furthering all
that on health it's not the case that
it's always that way and on a couple of
occasions I have worked with seen you
know witnessed narcissistic people who
can make changes now it's usually in the
context of something very extreme that
causes them to do that so someone who
will no longer have access to family
members they want to see or to financial
resources that they you know need to
keep themselves afloat it's things that
often are that dramatic it's not always
that but we can see though in those kind
of extenuating situations where the the
problem is so big the Envy is so high
but the motivation for change is very
very high because since on the carrot
and stick model the stick here is very
very strong that if a person then goes
and does that you you can see change
inside of them so we're never in a place
of of therapeutic nihilism but the but
the the barriers to that are very very
high because the self is so wounded that
the person is protecting that self so
strongly that's why the narcissism and
envy are so full-blown and it's hard to
get that person to go back and look but
not impossible based on what you're
telling me it seems that it's a very low
probability that a non-clinician could
change a narcissist like in other words
if one is engaging in the world with a
narcissist
um because they have to presumably or
they just find themselves in that place
um would you say to that person there's
very little if anything that you can do
to change the narcissist Behavior or
um psychological framework if they for
because of course if the narcissist
can't often do it for themselves with
the help of a skilled clinician why
would a um why would anyone else be able
to achieve that so we're coming at what
we're doing here from a perspective of
truth about human beings right and that
truth brings with it hopefulness right
it brings with it hopefulness that
people can change and how people can
change and and and I am a hundred
percent all for that it's the way to
look at ourselves right but it is also
true that there are aspects of pathology
that that require clinical treatment in
order to improve so now we're looking
from the other side and saying hey
there's a problem here and there's a
deep problem here and that we have to
come at from a different perspective of
how can you help that problem and
there's a science behind this too of
what level of clinical care for example
is most likely to be helpful to someone
like this and it's not an individual
clinician even right it's a team of
people who work through different
modalities you can say wrap around that
person so it's not just a level of
clinical care is needed but it's a
relatively high level of clinical care
and that in general is the is the only
way that we get it narcissism that's not
a hundred percent but that's the vast
majority of time so what can then the
person do right a person cannot be a
team of clinicians right what that
person can do one choice is to disengage
right but disengagement can come with
the promise of re-engagement right many
many times I've worked with people and
practiced and rehearsed with them like
okay what might you say to someone along
the lines of you know I've known you for
a long time or I care about you or I
love you right whatever they may say to
lead in but I I can't be with you or I
can't be around you right there's
there's something going on that that
makes it not okay for me it doesn't feel
okay you're in person maybe he says
things like you know you're aggressive
or demeaning or whatever it is or maybe
they just say it just doesn't feel okay
I can't have it and and then the the the
need to stay step away from the person
but look if you if you got some help
right if you took better care of
yourself in ways that would be better
for you and for the people around you
then of course I'd want to be in your
life you know something like that so
disengagement can come you know with
that
um encouragement right to the person but
but one way or another you have to set
boundaries which is okay I have to deal
with this person so I'll deal with them
a little bit
um or I don't have to deal with this
person so I won't right or I can't get
away from this person so I have to take
with a grain of salt what they're saying
to me but ultimately some form of strong
boundaries or disengagement is like
that's the response that that that's the
self-care response right for the person
who's with the narcissist what are some
other ways that the aggressive drive and
pleasure drive and generative drive for
that matter play out for instance we
talked about the former patient of yours
who eventually switched jobs
um clearly had a generative Drive within
him but it was being blocked by a number
of choices rooted in narratives that
originated in childhood Etc we talked
about individuals with high aggressive
Drive High degree of pleasure drive but
a very diminished capacity to experience
pleasure and therefore a lot of envy and
the destruction that comes with Envy yes
what are some of the other variations on
these drives As You observe them in your
clinical practice well our overall
framing is we want the generative drive
to be the one that's deterministic right
it's the one with the strongest
influence so we want to we want to
nurture the generative Drive in us and
in others and and it makes sense for us
to talk about that but we've looked at
how do things get out of balance right
and from the perspective of well what if
the aggressive drive or the pleasure
Drive what if they're too high right and
then it makes sense that often not
always what can be driving them to be so
high are things that aren't healthy in
us then the higher they get the harder
it is to gratify them so we end up with
that problem of Envy right but we can be
out of balance in the other direction
too right where where the person does
not does not experience an ability to
engage with the world around them right
they they don't think they can do
anything to change anything for the
better inside or outside of themselves
and you know they're not doing much they
don't feel that they can do much and and
and also not receiving pleasure from
things there's no gratification from the
things a person is doing like we see
situations like this too with the
aggressive Drive the pleasure drive or
both and then we end up not at Envy
because Envy is the side of excess but
we end up at demoralization on the lower
side now demoralization is not a
specific psychiatric diagnosis it can
predispose to psychiatric problems like
the biochemical abnormality of
depression right but what we're talking
about here is not a psychiatric
diagnosis right like Envy is not a
psychiatric diagnosis like it's a it's a
thing that can be experienced that can
lead to diagnoses the same thing with
demoralization if you don't feel that
you can make a difference to anything
right and you're not enjoying anything
or feeling gratification from anything
then that pool is going to win out
that's going to be a demoralized person
the same way of course we know in
experiments when you know the the you
know you have a a rat going for food if
like if you do it enough when the rat
goes through the food and you take the
food away the rat stops trying and they
learned helplessness right that exists
in us too and it comes along with all
sorts of other things because being not
hats right we have a whole bunch of
thoughts about that of oh my God I'm not
good enough and nothing will ever be
okay and you know so demoralization then
is is that can be very very strong in
taking a person away from the other
things we're trying to seek right either
because that person has the essentially
the Learned helplessness right and all
the things the complicated things inside
of us that can come along with that or
the person isn't gaining pleasure from
anything so when when we're considering
the ways in which we can be out of
balance right we think okay aggression
and pleasure drive if if one or the
other or both is too high we end up at
envy and if one or the other or both are
too low we end up with demoralization
and you can take almost any scenario it
could be a scenario of something that's
just not really not going well for a
person it's not a clinical scenario it's
a thing in a person's life or we can
take clinical scenarios and the vast
majority you know outside of outliers
like a head injury for example we can
take those scenarios and we can look at
it in that way and we can understand
what's going on at least we can
understand enough that when we go back
and look in the ten cupboards of the two
pillars we can then have some
understanding of okay what is going on
we know the basic picture and how things
are not in uh in the balance we want
them in now we can understand that
enough to go back and then look in those
10 cupboards and and I believe that just
about everything except those biological
outliers like a head injury fits into
that heuristic which is why we can use
it to understand we can use it to help
we can use it to make change
what a powerful lens to think about and
explore the self and where things are
working for us and where things are
possibly not working for us
if I or anyone else out there wanted to
get some read on assess their level of
aggressive drive and their level of
pleasure drive and their ability to
experience pleasure what sorts of
questions would one ask you know um for
instance uh is it a question of like how
driven am I
um how how much get up and go do I have
um how much pleasure do I experience
from an interaction with a puppy and
interaction with food um is it too much
right like does it draw me off course
are those the sorts of very simple but
I'm perhaps also very informative
questions that we could start to use to
probe our psyche yeah I think yes but I
would come top down right so if if the
goal of health is that aggression and
pleasure those drives are subserving the
generative driving start to look there
right if a person can take so an honest
inventory of self like what kind of
force am I being
in the world around me and and that
could mean for example what kind of
force am I being in my family right am I
denigrating to the people around me are
the other people in the home afraid of
me like what kind of force am I being a
Force for good am I bolstering like
it people can't always see that in
themselves and take stock of themselves
but what we're talking about a situation
where we think a person can like they
can bring to bear who am I being in the
world in other ways if you think of the
example of the person who needed to
leave the job who who could look at that
and say say no I'm not you know I'm not
being generative in the world in the way
I want to I'm certainly not doing my job
as well as I would want to I'm making my
own life worse right so so that person
could then see that's out of balance or
in another way a person might see you
know a lot of what I'm doing is sort of
self-serving or maybe destructive like
people can realize that right so you can
realize by taking an inventory of self
is is the generative Drive what's
deterministic in me and again not always
but we're talking about a process of
exploration if the answer to that is yes
if you say look I'm trying to be the
best person that I can and I think about
the people over whom I have any
Authority right and like I try to be
reasonable and I try to be fair and I
try and be certain respect and you know
I try and think in someone else's shoes
I mean you know sometimes I have to set
boundaries or expectations or even
punishment right but but I'm like
careful about how I'm doing that and I'm
certainly not perfect and I get things
wrong at times but you know I do think
I'm contributing to the world I'm doing
whatever I take on you know as well as I
can do it I'm productive at work I you
know my kids are doing okay or my
friends are are doing all right whatever
it is that if we can come up with that
then then we can say Okay exhale a
little bit like you're in a good place
right it doesn't mean everything is
optimal of course so then go look at the
level of the aggressive Drive which
might mean you know how assertive am I
right am I the kind of person who comes
up to the precipice but does it make the
decision am I the kind of person who's a
little too assertive and sometimes I'm
sort of walking on people a little bit
like a person can go look at the
aggressive Drive within them or pleasure
seeking am I doing things that bring me
gratification right am I engaging with
the people around me in a way that
brings the guy ratification that one
might one might wish for right so if
it's in a romantic relationship is there
romance like are we being nice to one
another right so so you can go and look
at that and say am I getting
gratification from the things I'm doing
right am I in am I taking this wherever
this drive is within me and trying to
satisfy it in reasonable healthy ways
that are also good for others and we're
back to the generative drive so that's
one way of coming at it and it's the way
that we would like to because now
what do we try to do next and what can
we make things better right can we
optimize things okay things are okay
right but can we make them better but
let's say we see that the the the
generative drive is not winning the day
right and people can see that like look
I'm seeking
pleasure right it's why I got for
example I hear over and over that's what
that's why I got addicted to this
substance and now is not providing any
pleasure to me it is now making me
miserable right but but I wanted what it
was giving me again this doesn't mean
that the person just wants to have the
world's best time right it may mean that
they're really suffering a lot right and
the pleasure that that drug it gave them
was some relief from pain and this is
how many many people tragically ended up
becoming addicted to and dying from
opiates right because say the opiate
after the surgery or the opiate after
the injury then is soothing something
right and it's soothing something
because that person feels less bad about
something inside of them you hear this
all the time that that then Fosters
addiction so so that person looking for
pleasure this isn't something where we
would say in some light-hearted manner
that person took Chances with their life
I mean sometimes we'll see that but but
more and more what people are looking
for then is relief from suffering right
but we can get to that point where we
can ascertain for whatever reason that
the pleasure seeking is is too much and
if pleasure seeking an aggression are
too much we we become aware of
dissatisfaction right if you're if
you're relying too much on aggression I
always want my way it's not always going
to happen right or I always want that
pleasurable thing I always want to feel
better that also doesn't happen right so
so then that can guide us towards being
aware of where are those drives and if
the drives are high by how much uh
dissonance is created by the the what's
actually coming of the drive right
versus the level the drive is at so so I
guess it's a long way of saying yes to
your question but I would sort of come
top down because the generative Drive is
so important and it does gauge gate
forward like kind of where are we at you
know in the spectrum of like how healthy
am I or are there elements of unhealth I
want to kind of go after or you know am
I seeing things in myself that really
say things that are unhealthy are really
dominating my life are deterministic
like addiction you know just just one
example you know addiction things that
are self-destructive right because then
that's a place to then look at it more
through the clinical lens and maybe I
won't just talk to a trusted other you
know or and go get a book but maybe I
should and maybe I should have a
clinical care you know the example of
addiction is very potent
um and it also brings to mind the
perhaps
um less apparently dangerous situation
but one that I think is really common
where people have a certain amount of
aggressive Drive
they have a certain amount of pleasure
drive but there's a kind of um passivity
and draining out of the generative drive
or competing out of the generative drive
because of social media uh and the
reason I I bring this up is again not
because I dislike social media I rely on
and use social media for teaching and
learning extensively really but in going
back to the pillars that underlie
whether or not we
achieve an experience agency gratitude
peace contentment and Delight
within the pillar of function of self
there's this thing salience you know and
what we're paying attention to internal
and external and social media does seem
to me
a unique circumstance never before
observed in human evolution where you
have a near infinite number of
environments available to you and we
know that you know a picture is worth a
thousand words and a movie is worth a
billion pictures when it comes to
drawing our attention I mean you just
look at you give a young child even an
infant an iPad I mean that kid is in the
tunnel I don't necessarily think that's
a bad thing and their computers and
computer screens are going to be a part
of their lives now and forever
presumably
but it is the case that there are a lot
of people who
um perhaps have the propensity for a
strong generative drive but because they
also have a propensity for a pleasure
Drive they wake up they pick up the
phone they look at the phone you know
something captivates their attention
then they're thinking about that it
might be something that brings them
Delight but more often than not it's
something that brings them either mild
irritation or or mild entertainment
um maybe even intense entertainment for
a short while but very quickly minutes
and hours go by in which we are not
engaging in the world unless we are
posting valuable content
um and so social media is a bit of a of
a drain on these drives I mean it Taps
into these drives in very strong ways
and all one has to do is observe the
behavior of people in public spaces now
in airports on trains um even in their
cars and I mean people are essentially
watching TV all day long
and and it does it does concern me and I
raise it because
um I feel like it it can distract from
our generative Drive in a way that um
doesn't necessarily speak to any kind of
like deep character flaw or any kind of
subconscious narrative but just that
that salience
um cupboard uh is is like clearly
something within that salience cupboard
is is happening that's
um unprecedented
um and very very powerful and
potentially quite destructive yeah I
think
to understand this you know I I would
cite this belief I I believe this to be
true that human beings have a long
history of under appreciating the power
of the discoveries that are then in
their own hands so we discover gunpowder
how long until we're shooting each other
right we discover nuclear fission right
now are we going to destroy the planet
right so social media and since it's a
discovery it's a thing that comes from
what we've figured out as humans that
now is there in in front of us and big
powerful discoveries deserve to be
treated with respect right gunpowder is
very powerful and if people need to hunt
in order to survive a gunpowder can help
them Hunt without getting hurt and be
more successful right nuclear fission
can has provided some good things to
humanity but it can also destroy
Humanity so I think the same is true
here that what you're talking about is
something of immense power and you can
see how if it gets out of balance so so
let's use the saline so let's say the
social media is too Salient right that's
going to make a problem right if it's
too Salient in the sense that the person
is always looking at things that don't
make them feel good enough right well
that's not going to go well and that's
going to affect what's in those other 10
cupboards right and what is built on top
of it so then it gets into the
unconscious mind like Oh I thought I was
good enough until like now I'm looking
at all the social media and I realize
I'm not I mean this is people who treat
teens you know often talk about this
that you see something that you didn't
often see before where a person who
might have gotten through a lot of
formative years thinking like like oh
how I look is okay for example then is
bombarding themselves with social media
that tells them how they look is not
okay and then that changes absolutely or
perhaps
social media is just simply absorbing a
ton of time and energy but mostly time
that could be devoted to to a generative
Force right that's the that's the other
side of it so think about the example of
the person who I know it wasn't social
media but we were saying what if it were
social media that instead of 90 minutes
a day you know it's it's eight hours
because there's an analog there right
and we see a lot of this and it's taking
something that that can be good right
and can in a sense essentially because
they even should be good like there's
enough out there right in terms of
learning and bolstering that like why
should it not be good right but it's not
good because the defenses then shift
like if you if you're relying on it 10
hours a day there has to be some denial
right because there are other things to
do in the world there has to be some
avoidance there has to be some
rationalization like something is going
on there that's not healthy so if you
tell me this person is utilizing social
media 10 hours a day they're not looking
at things that make them feel bad about
themselves they're just doing it then
and I think okay something is
is out of balance now it may be that
that that person's defenses are out of
balance so think about the example of
the person with the job they didn't like
then their defensive structure changes
then the thing that was good for them
they rely on too much and now become
something that's not good for them right
so then you go and look at what else is
out of balance here right what else is
is driving so maybe it's being driven by
the change in defense mechanisms Etc
maybe it's the other way around that
that this person just kind of habituated
he's doing more and more and more and
more of it and then you would come at it
in a different way of okay can you can
you slowly but surely do less you know
replace the the time with things that
were good before because you could then
back that person out to where they were
before but you're not going to back the
person out to where they were before if
it's being driven by something else so
we again come to the Curiosity you tell
me that person is on social media 14
hours a day I'm curious right I want to
understand what what is what is the
balance of those drives right you've
just told me a very powerful point about
salience that doesn't sound like a good
one so already you're giving me clues
about where the drives are which means
where's that person at what's going on
in all those cabinets then you give more
information I sit and talk with the
person now you know you're going to
understand like what is the lay of the
land here and how do we go about making
it better
I love the concept of the generative
Drive first of all because it's
pro-social it brings about great things
for us and for for the world and I mean
what is better than peace contentment
and Delight especially when we remind
ourselves that those are active
phrases or those those can be achieved
and experienced inside of action it's
not just sitting levitating Naval gazing
that sort of thing so it's not
Enlightenment right it's peace
contentment and Delight
um
very big difference very very big
difference yes one of the other reasons
I love this concept of the generative
drive so much is also because it is a
verb state it has to do with creating
things in us and in the world in
cultivating our experience of things and
and what we do and what we say and how
we respond to what others do and say
and I also like it because
it's distinct from the way that we're
normally taught to think about
psychological well-being or being a
healthy individual which is usually
centers around a discussion of goals and
values and you know like what am I
trying to focus on and you know what
sorts of people do I want to engage with
in the world and certainly all of that
is really important goals and who you
engage with but I think for many people
out there much of their time is spent
thinking about other people like how
healthier or unhealthy are the the
people they're dating or their friends
or what's going on between two family
members you know which of course is fine
to think about but a lot of emphasis is
placed on like our assessments of others
and how those are impacting us
um and in some cases people default to
just thinking about others and their
problems and seeing their problems and
what we're really talking about here is
a process of introspection and inquiry
that's very structured and as it's been
laid out by you you know these two
pillars structure of cell function of
self with these 10 covers
um that might sound like a lot of
cupboards but as we talked about in the
first episode all of that flows up to
these very simple right ideals and
Concepts and action States and ways of
being and to me there's nothing more
powerful than the statement that what we
are all seeking are states of agency and
gratitude because again to go back to
the analogy of physical fitness
there are not an infinite number of
different physical States or states of
Fitness that one
um can seek there's endurance their
strength their flexibility there's
Dynamic movement there's you know
explosiveness there's speed there are a
bunch of you know subtleties to it but
here it really seems that
the psyche ourselves and our mental
health is really tractable if we turn
the lens and we look inward yes yes I
think that hits upon a very very
important Point as we talk about
understanding oneself in the process of
change right and I would describe that
as rational aspiration right so let's
use the physical health example right if
if I think okay I want to be healthier
you know I want to have more strength I
want to have more endurance and I might
even have ideas of what that would be I
want to be able to run a certain
distance in a certain time lift a
certain amount of weight I have an idea
of what that is but rational aspiration
is rooted in our present or like I'm
aware that there's a me now that that
like isn't in that state and I'm aware
that there's a the things that I'm going
to do to get to that state right and I'm
not that dreading them like okay they'll
be difficult right but that's okay I can
do difficult things I can take pride in
doing difficult things and that's how we
all achieve things so I see myself in
the present because of course goals are
good and that's true as long as we're
still living our lives in the present
because otherwise goals just become
fantasies or things we want to want to
possess so if I'm aware of the state of
physical health I'm in right now and I'm
aware of the state of physical health I
want to be in and I know there's a bunch
of Pathways I could take to get there
but I have to think about it about it
figure it out do those things and then
I'm going to navigate myself there
that's how the whole process is good
right I don't feel bad about myself now
I recognize something I would like to
change I'm not saying oh you're a loser
because you don't have those things
right I feel I feel good about myself
now I recognize there's something I want
and there's going to be a process a
process across time across effort that's
going to navigate me there then when I
get there I feel good about being there
right it's very very different if I
think I want that I want to possess in a
sense right I want to possess the
ability to run a certain distance in
time I just want the thing I'm Covetous
of the thing right that is not good
right because the person then often is
denigrating to the self not always but
that's a motivation to go out and get
that thing that's better and and they're
they're really um lamenting the process
of getting like they just want something
as an end point and that doesn't make
for happiness it doesn't make for even
the humility and humility in action the
Gratitude right of the humility is I
can't just do that overnight I'm going
to have to work hard people have to work
hard I'm no different than anybody else
I'm not special I got to get in there
and work and use the elbow grease and
then I'll get healthier like all of that
is good that I just want to possess
something is not good and that's why
people in in scenarios like this they
might like go through maybe in an
unthinking way or they're gutting it out
wherever they go and they get that thing
right but then that thing is not enough
right and they want more now there's not
there's nothing wrong with wanting more
if it's if it's the healthy and action
of self right I'm going to Now map my
way this feels better I want to map
myself from here to the next level of
better physical fitness
that's different than I just want that
thing because then if I get it it won't
be good enough right it doesn't make me
happy it doesn't satisfy me and that's
the that's the the unhealthy state of
just wanting things to possess them and
then we don't feel good about them which
is you know the thought of if you give
people if you give a person something
they'll resent you for it right again
that we're painting in a certain way the
context of that statement which I used
to hear you know a lot even when I was
younger like people would say that right
and what were they trying to get at
right what they were getting at is it
doesn't feel good if you didn't work for
something right like if you didn't work
very hard and you got to see but I give
you an A or somebody gives me an a right
I know that that's not good I know that
I got the thing I got the A and I might
feel happy in the moment because I
wanted that thing but there's no
real pleasure in it there's no
satisfaction there's no contentment
there's no sense of self there's nothing
generative I didn't work hard enough to
go from a c to an a right so it's that
that uh and and that really brings us
back to the self that we're growing on
top of you know of the structure right
and how that how that self is
functioning right how it's striving
because now we're really talking about
strivings and if I'm going to strive for
something and work hard to get it will I
get the good feeling on the other side
of it and now we're living in the
generative space
well I love the structure of what you've
laid out again thank you the pillars of
structure of self and function of self
with 10 cupboards between the two of
them that when explored can seem a
little bit complex but they're really
some very straightforward types of
inquiry that anyone can go about about
self-awareness and address potential
defense mechanisms what we're conscious
of maybe what we're not conscious of
look at our behaviors and our strives
and how that flows up to these simple
ideals again of empowerment humility
agency and gratitude as verbs and then
from that peace contentment and delight
and the generative Drive which gosh if
if there ever was a more powerful
concept and something to strive for I I
don't think it exists because
um the generative Drive is is
extraordinary in in the number of
different ways it plays out and it seems
always positively right
um and of course the aggressive Drive
the pleasure Drive exists to varying
extensions in all of us but
um
cannot be allowed to overcome the
generative drive if we're going to to
Really Thrive so um so thank you again
so much for this framework and again to
remind people listening and watching
that this framework is is mapped out in
a downloadable PDF if people want to see
it visually even though we've touched on
it several times before
um I really appreciate how logical clear
and actionable this framework is and um
and also that in providing a framework
for us it gives us something to hold our
mind to you know I think I and so many
people out there are familiar with like
being in a struggle and and not being
able to orient like like where am I in
the struggle not knowing what to do and
you've provided some incredible points
of reference for us to really like focus
on start asking questions about I and
how I see myself what am I paying
attention to and so on and so forth to
really first anchor and Orient and then
be able to move forward in this process
as many times as it's required to get
where we each and all want to go oh so
thank you so much for this I know in our
next discussion we're going to touch on
the relational aspects of
human existence you know and not just
selves but interactions between selves
including some of the um let's call it a
darker and unfortunate aspects of of
human existence like narcissists and um
some of the challenges of different you
know full-blown personality disorders
but also just in terms of building
healthy relationships between friends
romantic Partners parents and children
and siblings and and co-workers and and
all the rest
so thank you again for this incredibly
Rich
um knowledge that you provided us and
and a map forward
you're very welcome and thank you I
appreciate the opportunity to talk about
it with you great well to be continued
thank you for joining me for today's
discussion about how to improve your
mental health with Dr Paul Conte if
you're learning from and or enjoying
this podcast please subscribe to our
YouTube channel that's a terrific zero
cost way to support us in addition
please subscribe to the podcast on both
Spotify and apple and on both Spotify
and apple you can leave us up to a
five-star review please also check out
the sponsors mentioned at the beginning
and throughout today's episode that's
the best way to support this podcast if
you have questions for me or comments
about the podcast or guests that you'd
like me to consider hosting on the
huberman Lab podcast please put those in
the comment section on YouTube I do read
all the comments and if you're not
already following me on social media I
am hubermanlab on all platforms so
that's Instagram Twitter LinkedIn
threads and Facebook and on all those
platforms I discuss science and science
related tools some of which overlap with
the content of the huberman Lab podcast
but much of which is distinct from the
content of the Hebrew and Lab podcast so
again it's huberman lab on all social
media channels not on today's episode
but on any previous episodes of the
huberman laptop cast we discuss
supplements while supplements aren't
necessary for everybody many people
derive tremendous benefit from them for
things like enhancing sleep for hormone
support and for Focus if you'd like to
see the supplements discussed on the
Hebrew and Lab podcast you can go to
live momentous spelled ous so it's
livemomentis.com huberman if you haven't
already subscribed to our newsletter it
is a zero cost newsletter called the
neural network newsletter and in the
neural network newsletter you get free
podcast summaries as well as tool kits
the toolkits are brief PDFs that list
off the specific science-backed
protocols for things like improving your
sleep improving Focus optimizing
dopamine deliberate cold exposure we
have a complete summary of our fitness
series again all available completely
zero cost you simply go to
hubermanlab.com go to the menu scroll
down to newsletter and provide your
email to sign up we do not share your
email with anybody thank you once again
for joining me for today's discussion
with Dr Paul conti and last but
certainly not least thank you for your
interest in science
thank you
[Music]